EXCITED TO HAVE HIM HE'S GOING
TO HE'S GOT YOU KNOW PRESENT
OUR FIRST BILL WE'RE WE'RE
GONNA CALL THE SENATE COMMITTEE
ON ENVIRONMENT QUALITY TO ORDER.
AS YOU KNOW WE HAVE MADE VERY
SIGNIFICANT ADJUSTMENTS THE
NORMAL PRACTICES IN ORDER TO
ENSURE THE PUBLIC. CONTINUES TO
HAVE ACCESS TO THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS WHILE WE AT THE SAME
TIME TO. ENSURE THAT WE ARE.
DOING OUR PART IN. FIGHTING THE
SPREAD. OF COVERT NINETEEN. SO
WE'RE HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE
HEARINGS HERE IN THE SENATE
CHAMBER TODAY. BUT WE DO HAVE
SOME OF OUR COMMITTEE MEMBERS
FROM PARTICIPATING REMOTELY
TODAY WE HAVE CENTER BATES
SENATOR STERN AND SENATOR.
SKINNER ALL PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY SO IF WE COULD ASK
EACH OF THEM I DON'T BELIEVE
THE CENTER SKINNER IS INNARDS
DESK YET BUT WE CAN DO FOR
LEAST. HAVE THE OTHER TWO
SENATORS. I GUESS JUST HAVE
CENTER BATES NOW IS HE IS AS I
BELIEVE IN THE CAN ALSO
IDENTIFY HER. STAFF MEMBER
PRESENT. PART WILL COME BACK TO
YOU WILL COME BACK TO YOU NO NO
PROB SO LET ME JUST BY. FOLKS
THAT YOU GOT A NEW YOUR PHONES
OR COMPUTERS- WE ALSO WANT TO.
MAKE SURE THAT. HAVE YOU SOME
INSTRUCTIONS FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE
REMOTE AND WE'RE GONNA THEY'RE
NOT REMOTE YET SO. JUST THE- WE
HAVE A WAY FOR PEOPLE TO
PARTICIPATE FROM ALL OVER THE
STATE IN IN THESE HEARINGS WE
HAVE A PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE
NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE IS
POSTED ON OUR- SAID
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. WE HAVE A PARTICIPANT
NUMBER IT'S ONE EIGHT FOUR FOUR
TWO NINE ONE. 964-844-2916
THREE SIX FOUR ACCESS CODE IS
SEVEN ZERO ZERO. EIGHT THREE
SIX ONE. AND THERE'S A WHOLE
PROCESS FOR PARTICIPATING. SO
WE'VE GOT FIVE BILLS ON TODAY'S
AGENDA WE'VE GOT ONE ITEM ON
THE CONSENT COUNTED OUT SIDE OF
NUMBER TWO BEFORE WE HEAR
PRESENTATION ON THE BILL'S LESS
ESTABLISH A QUORUM MEMBERS.
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN HERE ALLEN HERE BATES.
DOLLY HERE DAILY HERE HELLO.
HELLO HERE SKINNER STERN. WHY
CASTING HERE QUORUM IS PRESENT
OKAY WE HAVE A QUORUM. WE'RE
GETTING A FIRST YEAR A MOTION-
FOR THE CONSENT CALENDAR I- I
HEARD SENATE WHAT KASKY HAS
MOVED THE CONSENT CALENDAR
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
IS ITEM NUMBER TWO. ALLEN FIVE
ALLEN AYE BATES. DALLY BY DALLY
HI HILL HI HILL I SKINNER.
STERN HOUSE HI I THINK COUNTY
DESPITE THE COLD BAYSIDE BATES.
FIVE TRANSACTION REQUIRED IT
OPEN THE SAN BATES IT'S
FANTASTIC TO SEE WE LOVE THE
VIEW TO RED MASS. WONDER WOMAN.
CAN YOU KNOW YOU DO S. FAVOR OF
I DON'T THIS. WHO IS WITH.
STAFFER WITH ME RELEASED IN.
YOUNG GUYS HERE WITH THE WERE
WARM SO WE'RE DOING OR- CONTEST
GOES GOOD GOOD GOOD GOOD RIGHT
WE APPRECIATE YOUR YOUR YOUR
REMOTE PRESENCE HERE OUT OF HIS
CHAIR AND YOU KNOW WE WILL BE
WILL BE CHECKING ACCOUNT RECORD
TO MAKE SURE THAT YOU'RE A TO
PRODUCE A- AS A ROBOT. AS YOU
AS YOU WOULD. THANK YOU ARE
WE'RE GOING TO HOLD THE OPEN ON
THE CONSENT BE THAT OF OUR
MEMBERS AND NOT HAVE A TO ADD
YEAH. AND WE THAT LET'S GET
WITH ITEM ON A AGENDA IS THIS
IS A SEVEN NINETY THREE FILTER
BILL. AND ARE PREVENT COMMITTEE
MEMBER JERRY HILL WILL BE FOR
AT THE YOU MAY PROCEED WITH.
THANK THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND IT FIRST I WANT TO SURE
THAT YOU CLEAR THAT WE WILL BE
X. ALL OF THE MEN OUT IN THE.
LAST YEAR THE LEGISLATURE
PASSED SB SEVEN NINETY TO A
SUBSTANTIALLY SIMILAR BILL THAT
WAS VETOED BY THE GOVERNOR. THE
AUTHOR STAFF CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH THE ADMINISTRATION TO
ADDRESS COST CONCERNS. THAT
WERE HIGHLIGHTED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S VETO MESSAGE. AROUND
THE WORLD THERE IS A CLEAR
PROBLEM WITH WASTEFUL PROP
PLASTICS. IF WE CONTINUE TO
PRODUCE THE SAME AMOUNT OF NEW
PLASTICS THAT WE ARE TODAY.
THEN BY TWENTY FIFTY THERE WILL
BE MORE PLASTIC IN THE OCEANS
THAN FISH. ADDITIONALLY
NATIONAL CLIMATE CHANGE FOUND
THAT THAT MIGHT MAKE IT A
PLASTICS WILL COME. COMPROMISED
OR COME COMPROMISED 15% OF GHG
EMISSIONS. THE SAME AS
TRANSPORTATION TODAY. THERE'S A
CLEAR NEED TO ACTUALLY RECYCLE
PLASTICS IN THE STATE AND NOT
JUST SHIP IT TO ANOTHER
COUNTRY. SETTING UP A MINIMUM
CONTENT STANDARD. WAS IN ALL OF
IT WILL NOT ONLY BENEFIT THE
ENVIRONMENT BY PRODUCING LESS
NEW PLASTIC. IT WILL RESULT IN
LESS PLASTIC BEING DUMPED IN
LANDFILLS AND BENEFIT
CALIFORNIANS. CALIFORNIA'S
RECYCLING MARKET A FEW KEY
WITNESSES TO THIS MORNING
MISTER CHAIR MARK MURRAY
CALIFORNIANS AGAINST WASTE. AND
PETER. DAVIS WALLY NESTLE.
WATERS OF NORTH AMERICA. OKAY
ARE THEY PRESS ON THE PHONE
LINES BECAUSE I GUESS THERE'S I
THINK MARKET PETER JUST JUST
JOINT OKAY FANTASTIC SO LET'S.
LET'S GO TO THE PHONE LINES AND
WE'LL HEAR WE'LL HEAR FROM THEM
SO THEY CAN PRESENT- THEIR
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT. OF THIS
BILL THIS IS MARK MURRAY AND
PETER TO POSSIBLY. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN THIS IS MARK
MURRAY WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF AB
SEVEN NINETY THREE AND ARE
CONTINUING TO WORKWITH THE
AUTHOR IN THE COMMITTEE STAFF
TO ENSURE THAT WE GET A
GOVERNOR SIGNATURE ON THE
MEASURE. WE'RE GRATEFUL TO THE
EFFORTS OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CHIANG AND- THE COMMITTEE
CHAIRMAN AND STAFF AND BRINGING
THIS MEASURE- THIS CRITICAL
MEASURE AT A TIME WHEN YOU KNOW
WE'RE ALL KIND OF FACING OTHER
COMPLICATIONS I ALSO DO WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE VISION OF CENTER
WHITE HOUSE SKI WHO INITIALLY
PROPOSED A SIMILAR MEASURE TWO
YEARS AGO. NOW THERE ARE MANY
ENVIRONMENTAL AND ECONOMIC
BENEFITS FOR MATERIAL
RECYCLING. BUT THE GREATEST
BENEFIT MAY BE THE DISPLACEMENT
OF EXTRACTED VIRGIN RAW
MATERIALS. AS THE SOURCE OF
PRODUCTS AND PACKAGING WITH
RECYCLED MATERIAL. THIS CLOSED
LOOP RECYCLING MEANS THAT WE
REDUCE AND EVEN AND WILL
ELIMINATE THE ENVIRONMENTAL
DAMAGE CAUSED BY MATERIAL
EXTRACTION AND PROCESSING.
CALIFORNIA HAS LED THE NATION
IN REQUIRING RECYCLE CONTENT IN
PRODUCTS AND MATERIALS WITH THE
NATION'S FIRST RECYCLED CONTENT
REQUIREMENTS ON PAPER AND GLASS
MORE THAN A DECADE AGO. AND
WITH THIS MEASURE CALIFORNIA
HAS AN OPPORTUNITY TO LEAD
AGAIN. BOB NOW WE APPRECIATE
THE SUPPORT OF MANY OF THE
BEVERAGE INDUSTRY WITH THE
CURRENT PROPOSAL BUT LET ME
SPEAK TO THOSE IN THE BEVERAGE
INDUSTRY THAT STILL MAY BE
RELUCTANT SUPPORT. NUMBER ONE
WE HAVE EXAMPLES IN THE
MARKETPLACE TODAY 1100%
RECYCLED CONTENT. PLASTIC
BEVERAGE PACKAGING THIS IS
TECHNICALLY FEASIBLE. NUMBER
TWO THE PRICE OF PREMIUM
RECYCLED FEEDSTOCK TODAY. IS
LOWER THAN THE PRICE YOU'RE
PAYING FOR PREMIUM VIRGIN
SPEECH BUT STOCK. JUST FIVE
YEARS AGO CLOSED LOOP RECYCLING
WILL NOT COST YOU MORE. AND
FINALLY YOU KNOW THERE'VE BEEN
CALLS BY SOME BANNING SUCH
PIECES OF PLASTIC PACKAGING.
INCLUDING PLASTIC BEVERAGE
CONTAINERS. HOWEVER SCIENCE
DEMONSTRATED. PT PLASTIC BOTTLE
THAT IS RECYCLED AND EIGHTY
PERCENT. OR BETTER RATE. IT IS
MADE WITH 50% OR MORE RECYCLED
CONTENT MAY HAVE THE LOWEST
ENVIRONMENTAL FOOTPRINT OF. ANY
COMPETING MATERIAL TYPE. THE
50% RECYCLE CONTENT PROVISION
IN S. B. IN AB SEVEN NINETY
THREE REPRESENT A CRITIC BEST.
AND REALLY AN OPERA FOR THE
BEVERAGE INDUSTRY TO REALIZE
PACKAGING SUSTAINABILITY. AS
THIS MEASURE MOVES FORWARD IT'S
NOT IN THE INTEREST OF THE
BEVERAGE INDUSTRY TO DRAG THEIR
FEET ON A PATH TO FIFTY
PERCENT. WE RESPECTFULLY URGE
AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU SO MUCH
MARK- WILL NEXT HEAR FROM PETER
THE BEST QUALITY FROM. NESTLE
WATERS NORTH AMERICA. THANK YOU
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE I NEED TO SPEAK ABOUT
SCHOOL ON THE VICE PRESIDENT OF
GOVERNMENT RELATIONS FOR NESTLE
WATERS NORTH AMERICA WE ARE
PLEASED TO SUPPORT EIGHTY SEVEN
NINETY THREE. WE ARE ONE OF THE
NATION'S LEADING BOTTLED WATER
COMPANIES. OUT OF THE ROLE THAT
WE'RE PLAYING TO ENHANCE
QUALITY OF LIFE YOU CONTRIBUTE
TO A HEALTHIER AND MORE
SUSTAINABLE FUTURE. EMPLOYEES
TAKE PRIDE TO WORK WITH
CALIFORNIA BASED ORGANIZATIONS
DON'T EIGHT HUNDRED THOUSAND A
GALLON OF WATER TO COMMUNITIES
IMPACTED BY THE CO THE NINETEEN
PANDEMIC AS WELL AS THOSE
IMPACTED BY THE WILDFIRES WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THE INCREASED
USE OF OUR SITE WITH CONTENT.
HAVE DEMONSTRATED. INTO
LEADERSHIP IN IT YOU. IN THE
WAITING ROOM FOR CONTENT HI. IS
CRITICAL FOR THIS ECONOMY WE
AREN'T AVAILABLE ACROSS THE US
IS HERE CAL. BECAUSE MANY
AUTHORS AND STAFF TO WORKING
FASHION STRAW MEASURE I WILL
HAVE TO FIGURE IMPACT
CALIFORNIA GLOBAL LEADER IN
RECYCLED CONTENT. LIKE SOME OF
THE OTHER BEVERAGE
MANUFACTURERS WE HAVE MADE
COMMITMENTS TO INCREASE THE USE
OF RECYCLED CONTENT THROUGHOUT
OUR. OWN PORTFOLIO. ALL THESE
COMPANIES TO CHEAT KERN COMMIT
TO CONTINUE MAKING YOU. THIRTY
BE ON WILL OFTEN. FIVE GRADE
CONTENT WE ARE ENCOURAGED BY
HISTORIC INTEREST THAT CAL.
INCREASE SUPPLY. THE MORNING
THEN IN COLLECTION. IS NEEDED.
WE BELIEVE IN PATIENT IN A BIG
THIRTEEN OF ALMOST LIKE A-
CANADA CAL. WILL SOLIDIFY CAN.
THEREBY STIMULATING THE NOT
FURTHERING. TO INCREASE WE-
FIVE. THE STAFF WAS SEEN
RECYCLED STANDARD LIKE THE ONE
EIGHTY SEVEN NINETY THREE WILL
ALSO WE ALIGN AND MARKET USE SO
THAT MORE FOOD GRADE RECYCLED
CONTENT. IS RECYCLED BACK INTO
FOOD GRADE APPLICATIONS. THE
STATE EXPERIENCE DRAKEN
RECLAIMS BEVERAGE CONTAINERS
DURING THE PANDEMIC. IN
RECOGNITION OF THE CHALLENGES
THAT HAD THE BILL PROVIDES
OPPORTUNITY TO REVISIT
PREVAILING MARKET CONDITIONS TO
DETERMINE WHETHER THE MINIMUM
CONTENT STANDARD SHOULD BE
ADJUSTED. WELCOME SAME TIME IT
CONTAINS STRONG ENFORCEMENT
PROVISIONS FOR NON COMPLIANCE
WITH FOUR TO WORKING WITH THIS
COMMITTEE TO SUPPORT POLICIES
LIKE EIGHTY SEVEN EIGHT THREE.
PROMOTED GREATER USE OF
RECYCLED CONTENT BEVERAGE
CONTAINERS. THANK YOU SHERMAN.
THANK YOU SO MUCH I APPRECIATE
THAT PETER. OKAY HELLO THE AYE
WHAT WHAT ELSE ELSE WE HAVE IN
SOME I DON'T SEE AN HERE THE
pI DON'T SEE ANYONE. IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE. LET'S GO TO ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINES YOU WANT TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
MODERATOR. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
TO SHOW SUPPORT FOR A BI SEVEN
NINE THREE YOU MAY PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONE MOMENT
PLEASE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE OPEN MY NUMBER NINETY
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON SURE MEMBERS BY EMAIL
CALIFORNIANS AGAINST WASTE
CALLING FOR ON BEHALF OF THE
NUMBER OF ORGANIZATIONS
INCLUDING YOUR CLUB CALIFORNIA
LEAGUE OF CONSERVATION VOTERS
THEIR FIGHTER FOUNDATION ONE
EARTH RECYCLING RETHINK WAIT
DEFENDERS OF WILDLIFE REPUBLIC
SERVICES FIVE VERY CAN YOU HEAL
THE BAY NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
RECYCLING ASSOCIATION. I THINK
LUCIEN COALITION FAVOR STORY I
THINK OCEAN INTERNATIONAL SEVEN
GENERATIONS ADVISORY UPSTREAM
WHICH CHOI CHU MARCHAND ASIAN
AND YOUR WEIGHT. USA THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. I THINK THERE'S ONE
FINAL. MY DAUGHTER HAD HER.
NINE WHAT ARE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
YES- MISTER CHAIRMAN OF THE
COMMITTEE PUBLIC STREET-
WHOLEHEARTEDLY SUPPORTING FOR
IMPACT CARDINALATE YOU CYCLING
FOR DECO MARYLAND IN PARTICULAR
PLASTICS INDORAMA RPG ALL IN
FAVOR OF THIS. BILL WE ARE
DIRECTLY WORK THANK YOU. ONE OH
THREE OR LINE AND OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON KAREN MEMBERS CHRIS
BUT YOU DON'T ON BEHALF OF THE
FOLLOWING THE ONLY POSITION OF
NORTH AMERICA'S LEGISLATIVE
TASK FORCE STOP WAIT CALIFORNIA
PRODUCTS YOU SHOULD CANCEL AND
WESTERN AFTER WASTE MANAGEMENT
AUTHORITY IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ONE ONE FOURTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HELLO THIS IS DENNIS ALL
THE ON THE ON THE HEALTH OF THE
AMERICAN BEVERAGE ASSOCIATION
AND THE PLASTIC RECYCLING
CORPORATION CALIFORNIA WE
SUPPORT. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
TO SHOW SUPPORT. FOR EIGHTY
SEVEN NINE THREE PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. I WANT
TO GET SHOW SUPPORT FOR EIGHTY
SEVEN NINE THREE B. PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. NO ONE ELSE
WANTED PORTER PLEASE CONTINUE.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU THANK YOU
SO MUCH- I BY THE WAY THE
COMMITTEE NOTES THE PRESENCE OF
OUR OF OUR COLLEAGUE A CENTER
STERN. I IF YOU WANTED TO SAY
HELLO SENATOR AND ALSO
INTRODUCE YOUR STAFF I BELIEVE
IT'S JEREMY WOLF BUT- IF THAT'S
NOT THE CASE OTHER THERE'S
JEREMY'S. JEREMY'S GERMANY'S
BEAUTIFUL RESIDES THEIR
STRUGGLE HERE SHORTLY OKAY NOT
HERE YET OKAY I WAS JUST ALWAYS
ARE OKAY ALL RIGHT GREAT. LET'S
NOW GO TO OPPOSITION IS
ANYBODY- ANYBODY WANT TO SIGN A
PETITION I DON'T BELIEVE
THERE'S ANY MEASURE OF THIS FOR
THE BILL- BUT SIR WE WANT TO
GIVE PEOPLE OPPORTUNITY- WE
DON'T SEE PEPLE HERE IN THE
CHAMBER FOR THEIN ROOM ONE
TWELVE- BUT- IT IS IN ONE OF
THE PHONE LINES MODERATOR WHO
WANT TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. TO
AB SEVEN NINETY THREE NOW IS
THEIR TIME. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN TO SHOW OPPOSITION TO
AB SEVEN NINE THREE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THE TIME. TO
SHOW OPPOSITION FOR EIGHTY
SEVEN NINE THREE YOU MAY PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THE TIME. AND I
HAVE NO INSURANCE OPPOSITION TO
EIGHTY SEVEN NINE THREE OKAY
THANK YOU SO MUCH BROADER
APPRECIATE THAT. AS I SAY THAT
WE DON'T HAVE ANY OPPOSITION
REFLECTED IN THE ANALYSIS AND
YOU KNOW BY THE WAY THAT'S THE
RESULT OF A LOT OF REALLY HARD
WORK THIS IS NOT AN EASY AREA.
TO DO WORK- AS I KNOW AND AS A
FORMER TEACHER WHO KNOWS. AND
SO I WANTI JUST TWO ONE
APPRECIATE THAT THE HARD WORK
OF THE AUTHOR AND THE
SUPPORTERS AND ALL THE INDUSTRY
FOLKS AS WELL CAME TOGETHER TO
MAKE THIS TO MAKE TO BRING TO
TENTATIVE TO EFFECTUATE THIS
COMPROMISE SO. LET'S NOW. OPEN
IT UP TO DISCUSSION. FROM OUR
MEMBERS- I LIKE TO RECOGNIZE.
OUR CHAIR EMERITUS SENATOR BOB
KASKI MISTER. AND CHAIR THE
STAFF REPORT TALKS ABOUT THE
NARROW DEFINITION OF BOTTLE
GRADE WHICH PREVIOUSLY IS NOT
BEEN IN STATUTE HE THEN THEY
THINK GOES ON TO THE
AVAILABILITY OF PLASTICS AND I
WAS WONDERING IF I COULD HAVE A
CLARIFICATION ON HOW WE'RE- THE
AMENDMENTS LANDED ON JUST
APOLLO CREED DEFINITION. THAT
MAY HAVE BEEN TOO NARROW AND
DIDN'T INCLUDE. A LOT OF
POTENTIALLY RECYCLABLE PLASTIC
IT'S NOT CLEAR TO ME FROM
REPORT. I THANK YOU OKAY THIS
IS A IT'S A COMMITTEE MAY WISH
TO HAVE CONSIDER SUPPLYING
DEMAND POST CONSUMER RECYCLING
PLASTICS COLLECTION. BATES AND
BAIL AVAILABILITY DOMESTICALLY
AND GLOBALLY BUT THE DEFINITION
OF BILE. OF BOTTLE CREEK WAS
NARAL ON WHAT IS IN THE
UNIVERSE RIGHT WHEN SUPPLY AND
DEMAND ID. IT IS ONE THING SO I
GUESS I WANTED TO BE. SURE ARE
WE STILL USING BIO OR BOTTLE
GRADE AS A DEFINITION IN THIS
IN THE FINAL AMENDMENTS AND IF
WE ARE HOW IS THAT I DON'T HAVE
A COPY OF THE AMENDMENTS I
APOLOGIZE. MY UNDERSTANDING
THAT THE AND YOU KNOW OBVIOUSLY
THE PASSWORD THINGS ARE SO
TOUGH HERE BECAUSE WE DON'T
HAVE YOU KNOW THAT THE KEEP THE
STAFFER WHO WORKS ON THIS IS.
SO IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING THAT.
THE FIRST VOTE THE
CONSIDERATION BY CAL RECYCLE.
THIRD THEY'RE LOOKING AT THE
AVAILABILITY OF PLASTIC. PLUS
SIX WHAT GOES INTO CLAM SHELLS
WHAT GOES INTO THIS WHAT'S THE
MARKET CONDITIONS AND ALL THAT
TYPE OF STUFF BUT ON THE FRONT
END WE'RE SAYING WHAT HIS
BOTTLE GRADE WHAT IS NOT BOTTLE
GRADE. VERSUS SEEING THE PET OR
SOME OTHER CLASSIFICATIONS. FOR
A YEAH NO I YOUR POINTS WELL
TAKEN PRISON THE BULLY SIX
EXPAND THE UNIVERSE WHICH IS I
DON'T KNOW IF WE ARE STILL STOP
I GUESS QUESTION WOULD BE. ARE
WE STILL USING THAT. NEW
DEFINITION THAT'S NEVER BEEN
USED BEFORE AND WHAT VITAL
GREED IS IN AND TRYING TO
EXPAND THE MARKET SEN AND THE
AVAILABILITY LOOK AT THESE
OTHER CRITERIA IN ORDER TO GET.
THE RECYCLABLE. THE INCLUSION
OF MATERIAL TO REACH THE 50%
GOAL BY TWENTY THIRTY RIGHT
THOUGH THOUGH THOUGH I'M-
EUROPE SEE RIGHT THOUGH THOUGH
IF YOU NOTICE AND THE MORE
EXPLICITLY REQUIRING COVERS
LIKE- TO CONSIDER PLASTIC
GLOBALLY NOT JUST BASED ON
BOTTLE GRADE. SO I'M FRED SMITH
RICHARD THAT GOES TO WE CAN
IMPORT SOMEBODY ELSE'S PLASTIC
AND WE CAN BE THE NEW CHINA
TAILORED TO MAKE A 50% GRADE OR
WE CAN WORK WITHIN THE
COMMUNITY SO THAT. MORE OF THE-
CHEERLESS BEING USE HOW WE
DEFINE BOTTLE GRADE IS.
INCLUSIVE NASA AND THAT WE'RE
TAKING CARE OF OUR OUR DOMESTIC
MARKET I MEAN I WOULD LIKE TO
SEE THESE RIGHT B. CALIFORNIA
JOBS IN THE CALIFORNIA CIRCULAR
ECONOMY DID SAYING- WE HIT THE
SITES THE- BUT WE HAVE THE-
CONSTRICTING. DEFINITION SO
WE'RE IMPORTING PLASTIC FROM
QUAM VIRGIN ISLANDS AND ALL
THESE OTHER EXOTIC PLACES DO
YOU THINK IT MIGHT BE VALUABLE
TO PUT IN SOME LANGUAGE ABOUT
YOU KNOW WANTING TO GIVE
RELEASE WE HAVE TO RUN THIS BY
THE LAWYERS OF COURSE BUT- YOU
KNOW WITH THE MIND TOWARD. YEAH
IN IN IN STATE PRODUCTION HE IT
COULD BE I MEAN IF THE PROBLEM
IS THAT IF YOU WANT TO FIFTY
STATES THE DISTRICT STATES TO
BE FIFTY GROUPS THAT WOULD
COME. UP WITH DIFFERENT.
DEFINITIONS OF WHAT IS
AVAILABLE FOR. BOTTOM CREATED
IF YOU DON'T WANT TO GO. TO
FLOATED TO NINE THIRTY
INTEGRITY THE BILLS IN. THE
BOTTLES IN THE INTEGRITY OF.
THE HEALTH AND ALL THAT TYPE OF
STUFF BUT DON'T BE TOO.
RESTRICTIVE SAID THAT. WE'RE
ONLY USING. THIS NEW CLASS OF
PLASTICS WHICH COULD YOU KNOW
WE WANT TO DO AS MUCH AS WE CAN
I THINK THAT SORT OF AT THE END
OF THE DAY. MAYBE MISTER HILL
COULD YES IT LOOKS LIKE OUR OF
ALL THE JACQUI- WOULD LIKE TO.
LIKE TO RESPOND. IN CENTER
WHITE HOUSE HE RAISES A VERY
GOOD QUESTION AND THAT THE
AUTHOR HAS A- IS WAS PLANNING
TO REALLY ADDRESS THE BOTTLE
GRADE DEFINITION AND- IN
APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE
AMENDMENTS THAT WERE. PLACED
OKAY SO. IT'S NOT DONE YET.
MISTER HILL AND I WHO SERVE ON
THE APPROPRIATIONS FULL I
CONSIDER THIS ON MONDAY I GUESS.
MORE WEDNESDAY WHATEVER IT IS
THANK YOU NUMBER QUESTIONS ALL
MOVED THE BILL. APPRECIATE THAT
BUT I WILL SAY I AM ABSOLUTELY.
HAPPY FOR OUR- FOR OUR TEAMS IN
CENTER HILLS TEAM YOUR TEAM
OURS THE COMMITTEE. I THE
AUTHOR TO SIT DOWN AND SEE IF
THERE WOULD BE SOME SORT OF
WINNING TEAM. WINNING YOU KNOW
SO SOME SOME SORT OF LANGUAGE
HERE THAT MIGHT MIGHT HELP TO
RESOLVE SOME OF YOUR YOUR YOUR
YOUR YOUR CONCERNS. SENATE ALI.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MY OWN
CARE YES YOUR BEGINNER THANK
YOU. SO I JUST WANT TO THE
SPRINGBOARD MAYBE OFF OF THE
CONVERSATION BECAUSE I HAVE THE
SAME LOOK THE REASON YOU HAVE
COUPLE CONCERNS EVERYONE IS
THAT OBVIOUSLY THIS WILL MOVE
IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION WE HAVE
NO OPPOSITION ON THE BILL AND I
THINK WE'RE ALL TRYING TO GET.
TO A PLACE WHERE. YOU GOOD
SOUND RECYCLING WE HAVE NON
CONTAMINATED THE PROBLEM WITH.
RECYCLING IS YOU HAVE TO.
PACIFY IT SO IT'S NOT
CONTAMINATED YOU CAN REUSE. IT
INTO AN APPROPRIATE MANNER.
WITH THAT BEING SAID WE IN
RECENT THE INFORMATION I HAVE
YOU KNOW WE'VE SEEN MANY
COUNTRIES THAT ARE NOT TAKING
OURS WASTE BECAUSE IT'S
CONTAMINATED THEY CAN'T REALLY
YOU RIGHT LIKE THEY WANT SO
THAT THERE'S A IT'S A GLOBAL
PROBLEMS SOMETHING THAT. MAIN
TO CALIFORNIA EVEN THOUGH WE
ARE. FOCUSING ON. YOU KNOW 10%
BY TWENTY TWENTY TO. 25% BY
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE AND THEN.
FIFTY BUT I THINK IT'S 50% BY.
BY TWENTY THIRTY. SO I THINK
THE CHALLENGE HERE IS TO
DETERMINE WHAT IS THAT WHAT'S
THE AMOUNT WELL I MEAN WE DON'T
REALLY KNOW BECAUSE WE WE'VE
BEEN THROWING IT ALL INTO ONE
GIANT RECYCLING. OF BIN I GUESS
AND THEN WE'RE TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT WHAT IS THAT QUALITY THAT
IS AVAILABLE TO. RE USE IN A
SAFE MANNER- AND I THINK THAT'S
THE GOAL HERE SO. FOR ME I'M
I'M- I'M THINKING THAT YOU KNOW
WE'RE WE'RE MOVING RIGHT ALONG
RIGHT PASSED WE GOT TO
DETERMINE THAT BECAUSE YOU'RE
GOING TO HOLD THESE. COMPANIES
ACCOUNTABLE TO THOSE
PERCENTAGES AND MAYBE THAT
AMOUNT IS NOT AVAILABLE. OR
MAYBE IT IS WE DON'T KNOW MAYBE
THERE ARE SOME TECHNOLOGY OUT
THERE SO I GUESS. THERE THE
CONVERSATION IS I IN THIS IS
TOO BAD THAT THE AUTHORSNOT
HERE BUT I'M ASSUMING THERE'S
FACED WITH THE SAME ISSUE THAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT TODAY. TO
OUR HALLWAY OFF THE BILL- AND
SEE WHAT HAPPENS IN APPROACH
BUT I MAYBE WITH MAYBE WE CAN
GET SOME ANSWERS BETWEEN NOW
AND APPROPRIATIONS. ON YOU KNOW
HOW WE MOVE FORWARD. BECAUSE
THAT'S THE KEY IS THAT IF WE
CAN'T FIND THE MATERIAL. MORGAN
WE HOLD THESE. THESE WE WANT TO
FIRST OF ALL THE GOAL IS TO
RECYCLE BUT WE HAVE TO DO IT A
SAFE MANNER SO. I KIND OF I
JUST WENT THROUGH HERE AND TRY
TO FIND THAT INFORMATION WHEN I
WAS READING AND I DIDN'T FIND
THAT INFORMATION ON. HOW E GET
THERE. SO THAT'S MY QUESTION
IS. ARE THE COMPANY'S GONNA BE
HELD ACCOUNTABLE. TO THOSE
PERCENTAGES IF THE MATERIAL IS
NOT AVAILABLE. SENATE
HEALTHCARE OF MR MURRAY'S I
BELIEVE STILL ON THE LINE OUR
PRIMARY WITNESS AND I THINK HE
COULD MAYBE CLARIFY SOME OF
THESE ISSUES AND ENSURE. LET'S
GO LET'S TURN TO YOU AYE MR
MURRAY IF YOU'RE AVAILABLE TO
ANSWER SOME OF SENATE DOLLARS
CONCERNS MAYBE CAN ALSO
COMMENTED SOME OF CINEMA
CASKETS CONCERNS AS WELL.
CERTAINLY THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS AND- I WOULD JUST
SIMPLY NOTE THAT- TWO YEARS AGO
THE BEVERAGE INDUSTRY DID
RAISE. SUCH ACTION TO CENTER
WHITE HOUSE HE'S BILL AND I
UNDERSTAND WHY HE MAY HAVE THIS
CONCERN. BUT TODAY WE HAVE THE
BEST RECLAIMER IS IN THE
COUNTRY YOU'RE IN CALIFORNIA.
SO CALIFORNIA BEVERAGE
CONTAINERS ARE SEGREGATED FROM
THE REST OF PLASTIC AND THEY GO
TO. A HALF A DOZEN DIFFERENT
RECLAIMER IS THERE IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA WHO PROCESS JUST
A SINGLE MATERIAL P. E. T.
PACKAGING. AND THEY ARE
PRODUCING TODAY. WITH THAT
MATERIAL WITH RECYCLED MATERIAL
BEVERAGE PACKAGING AND OTHER
FOOD PACKAGING FOOD GRADE
PACKAGING BEVERAGE GET GREAT
PACKAGING. I THINK THIS TERM-
BEVERAGE GREAT MATERIAL- IS A
HOLDOVER FROM PREVIOUS BEVERAGE
INDUSTRY CONCERNS. AND WE HOPE
TO CLARIFY THAT IN THE
APPROPRIATIONS AMENDMENTS. BUT
KNOW THAT YOU HAVE PROPERLY.
EITHER RECLAIMING CONTEST IN
CALIFORNIA. EIGHT TEN. QUITE OF
THE TERMS OF PRODUCING FOOD
QUALITY RECYCLED. PLASTIC
PACKAGING FOR THERMAL.
PACKAGING WE CAN DO THAT TODAY
THE PROBLEM IS DON'T HAVE THE
SUPPLY. WE NEED TO INCREASE
RISK RATES AS MR. FROM WAS
REFERENCING. RIGHT AND IF I
UNDERSTAND IT RIGHT- THE BILL
ACTUALLY GIVES CAL RECYCLE
QUITE A BIT OF FLEXIBILITY-
POWER CYCLE IS ULTIMATELY
SUPPOSED TO YOU KNOW LOOK AT
THE SUPPLY PLASTIC WHEN
DETERMINING WHETHER TO ADJUST
THE MINIMUM SECOND CONTENT.
STANDARDS SO IT YOU KNOW
THERE'S EXACTLY MISTER CHAIRMAN
THIS IS A SUBJECTIVE THIS IS
ALL SUBJECTIVE OPPORTUNITIES
FOR CAL RECYCLE TO- INFORM IF
BEVERAGE OR OTHERS WERE TO
RAISE CAN. ABOUT WHY OF
SEDITION QUALITY. RECYCLE WOULD
HAVE THE AUTHORITY TO CONSIDER
THAT BUT THIS ISN'T SOME KIND
OF HARD AND FAST RULE AND KNOW
THAT WE HAVE AGAIN THIS IS
EXCELLENT RECLAIMING. AFTER
HEARING CALIFORNIA THAT IS
PROCESSING CALIFORNIA GENERATED
MATERIAL IN CAMBRIDGE.
SUFFICIENT LEVELS OF CALIFORNIA
GENERATED MATERIALS FOR
CALIFORNIA. FOOD AND BEVERAGE
PACKAGERS. IS THAT DOES THAT.
MASON CENTER I. YEAH MY MOST
ALONE THANK YOU OF COURSE I.
YEAH THAT WAS VERY HELPFUL- I
GUESS THE GRILL QUESTION IS
THERE ARE THEY GOING TO BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE IF THAT IF WE DON'T
PRODUCE THAT MATERIAL. IF THE
MATERIAL IS NOT AVAILABLE. THAT
I THINK I KNOW THAT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER EGGMAN AND I WORK WITH
THIS IS NOT THIS IS NOT NEW
OBVIOUSLY ALL OF US IN THIS.
ROOM HERE. HAVE WORKED ON THIS
IN ONE WAY OR THE OTHER. SO I.
MIKE IS. THIS LANGUAGE IN THIS
BILL HOLD THEM ACCOUNTABLE TO
ME- PERCENTAGE. IF THE MATERIAL
IS NOT AVAILABLE NO BE
IMPORTING THIS STUFF FROM ALL
OVER THE WORLD THAT IF THAT'S
THE CASE. YEAH IF YOU LOOK AT
THEM I THINK IT'S PAGE SIX
REBEL ATTACKS ABOUT HOW. POWER
CYCLE IS ABLE TO DECREASE THE
MINIMUM CONTENT REQUIREMENTS
BASED ON CHANGES IN MARKET
CONDITIONS. ARE RECYCLING
RATES- AVAILABILITY OF RECYCLED
PLASTICS SUITABLE TO MEET THE
MINIMUM CONTENT STANDARDS. IT'S
ADDRESS SO- THOSE ARE IF YOU
LOOK AT THE BOTTOM OF PAGE SIX
OF THE BILL. THE TALKS ABOUT.
JUST WHAT YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
BECAUSE I I'M I WOULD OF COURSE
MEAN BE. TO I WAS JUST LIKE WE
WERE TALKING ABOUT. IT ON ON
THE P. FAST ALL RIGHT YOU YOU
KNOW YOU YOU WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT. THERE IS AN ALTERNATIVE
IF YOU'RE GONNA. YOU KNOW A
FORCE A CHANGE SO. THIS IS THIS
THERE THERE IS. WE OBVIOUSLY
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT COVERS
LIKE WILL BE LOOKING AT ALL THE
MARKET FACTORS IN MAKING
CHANGES. AND TWEAKS BASED ON
THOSE REALITIES. ETCETERA
CASKET. MISTER CHARACTER BEEN
DOES WHO HAVE ARGUED THAT IF
YOU. IMPLEMENTED AN EXTENDED
PRODUCER RESPONSIBILITY PROGRAM
FOR BEVERAGE CONTAINERS AND
MOVE. ALL THE PLASTIC DRINK
BOTTLES ALL THE CLASS NOBODY.
OUT OF REACH. AND SEGREGATE
THEM IN HAD A OF TWO CENTS
INSTEAD A NICKEL HE THE 50%
GOAL WOULD BE CAKE BECAUSE THEN
ARE RECYCLERS WOULD BE DOING
THAT THEY'D HAVE THAT
SEGREGATED NUMBER ONE PETE BUT
IN ALL THE TWO THREES FOURS AND
FIVES WILL BE WITH. TRADITIONAL
NERFS WOULD BE DEALING WITH BUT
THAT'S NOT BEFORE US RIGHT NOW
BUT THIS IS THE CONTENT LEVEL.
I YEAH I THINK YOU HAVE- YOU
HAD A BILL ON THAT VERY TOPIC.
NEXT YEAR VERY. ALL RIGHT. YEAH
RUSSIAN I WANT TO ALSO
RECOGNIZE THE PRESENCE OF OUR
GOOD FRIEND SENATOR SKINNER WHO
IS HERE- WE ARE CURRENTLY
DEBATING AB SEVENTY THREE
SENATOR- IF YOU WOULDN'T MIND
TO SAY HELLO AND ALSO
IDENTIFYING ANY STOCK YOU MIGHT
HAVE WITH YOU IN YOUR OFFICE IF
THEY'RE THEY'RE- CERTAINLY- YES
HERE I AM PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY IN THE COMMITTEE AND
MY STAFF THAT'S WITH ME IS A
MARKER PANELING GREEDY OKAY
FANTASTIC IN YOUR YOUR DISTRICT
OFFICE. YES I AM OKAY GREAT
GREAT GREAT GREAT WAS GOOD TO
SEE SENATOR. OKAY SO I. OTHER
QUESTIONS THOUGHTS CONCERNS
ANYTHING DID YOU WANT TO
RESPOND ANYTHING I'M TOLD I'M
JUST TO RESPECTFULLY ASK WHEN I
MOVED HERE ARE ANY ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS FROM FOLKS ONLINE I
DON'T. EITHER OKAY OKAY- THE
BILL HAS BEEN MOVED BY YES
SENATE ALI BEFORE WELL I JUST
WANT TO SUPPORT THE BILL I
THINK WE'RE GOING IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION- I OBVIOUSLY WE WOULD
NOT SUPPORT IT IF WE DON'T IF
THERE SOMETHING COMES UP
BETWEEN NOW AND APPROPRIATIONS
BUT I. I TRUST- THE FOLKS THAT
ARE GONNA BE ON APPROPRIATIONS
TO UNDERSTAND THIS ISSUE TO GET
THAT'S WHERE WE'RE TRYING TO GO
IN A COMMON SENSE APPROACH I
JUST WANNA LET YOU GUYS KNOW
HOW WE SUPPORTING IT TODAY
THANKS FOR GOOD ART THANK YOU
YOU SENATOR AND WE WILL AS TO
THE LET'S KEEP THE SENATE ALLEN
OPENS THESE. AT ANY TEAM IN THE
LOOP AS IS AS- THEIR- SCALPEL
LITTLE THINGS ARE GETTING
CLARIFIED BUT I CERTAINLY
BELIEVE I AGREE WITH YOU
SENATOR. I BELIEVE WE PUT
ENOUGH FLEXIBILITY TO THE BILL
TO ENSURE THAT. NOBODY'S GONNA
BEATINGS FOR- HE FIRST SERVICE
YEAH ONE POSSIBILITY. SO WITH
THAT THE BILL HAS BEEN MOVED BY
OUR COLLEAGUE SENATOR WHAT
KASKY. A CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL ITEM NUMBER ONE AB
SEVEN NINE THREE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER TING THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO THE
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. ALLEN HI ALLEN AYE
BATES HI BATES I DALLY BY DALLY
I HILL HI HILL AYE SKINNER.
SKINNER HI SKINNER AYE STERN.
BY CASCADE BY MY CASKEY I'D SIX
ZERO OKAY SIX ZERO WILL HOLD
THAT ROLE OPEN FOR CENTER STERN
TO ADD ON WHEN HE'S READY AND
THANK YOU THANK YOU MEMBERS
FOR. THE ROBUST DISCUSSION.
ALRIGHT LET'S NOW GO TO A
CENTER MULLINS BILL ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MONTHS BILL IT'S AB
TWENTY SIX TWENTY ONE THIS IS.
REALLY NICE OPR ONE OF SEVERAL
CASKETS FAVORITE. FAVORITE
BRANCHES THE GOVERNMENT SAID
ORTEZ HE'S GOING TO PRESENT AB
TWENTY SIX TWENTY ONE YEAH
MISTER THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN COLLEAGUES AND I'LL
DRAW YOUR ATTENTION TO THE
STAFF REPORT BY MISTER WALTERS
THE POINTS OUT WITH THE
ESTABLISHING OF OPR TO HAVE ONE
AGENCY AT THE STATE LEVEL WHICH
IS RESPONSIBLE FOR DEVELOPING
DEVELOPING STATE LAND USE
POLICIES COORDINATING PLANNING
IS PLANNING OF ALL STATE
AGENCIES ASSISTING A
MONITORING. LOCAL AND REGIONAL
THE PLANNING SO THIS IS ON
POINT I'VE DONE SOME WORK IN
THIS AREA MR ASSEMBLY MEMBER
pCOMMITTEE STAFF FOR THE
ANALYSIS. AND HITS HE'S
ACCEPTING COMMITTEE OF
COMMITMENTS AS OUTLINED IN THE
REPORT. MEMBERS WE ALL KNOW
ABOUT CLIMATE CHANGE AND IT'S
HARD TO PROJECT WHAT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN IN THE FORESEEABLE
FUTURE BUT CURRENT AND
PROJECTED IMPACTS OF CLIMATE
CHANGE INCLUDE. EVERYTHING FROM
SEA LEVEL RISE TO SEVERE
DROUGHT THESE IMPACTS CAN
RESULT IN ADDITIONAL
CONSEQUENCES INCLUDING
DETRIMENTAL EFFECTS ON HUMAN
HEALTH SAFETY. ECOSYSTEM
INTEGRITY AND THE DELIVERY OF
BASIC SERVICES VERY- VERY BASED
ON THE COMMUNITIES FISCAL AND
SOCIAL CHARACTERISTICS SO THIS
IS A REGIONAL. THIS MAKES
REGIONAL COORDINATION BETWEEN
LOCAL REGIONAL AND STATE
GOVERNMENTS AS WELL AS
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
NONPROFITS PRIVATESECTORS. IN
ENTITIES. A VITAL COMPONENT A
RESILIENCY PLANNING SOUTH WE
HAVE. WE TALKED ABOUT- THE
STAFF REPORT TALKS ABOUT SOME
LOCAL AND REGIONAL AGENCIES
ACROSS THE STATE HAVE BEGIN THE
PROCESS OF PREPARING FOR THE
IMPACT OF CLIMATE CHANGE WE
HAVE PROVIDED SOME MONEY IN THE
STATE BUDGET NOT A LOT OF MONEY
BUT SPARINGLY EACH YEAR WE TRY
TO GIVE SOME MONEY TO WHETHER
TO BE CDC IN THE BAY AREA OR
THEIR- CULTURAL COMMISSION TO
DO SOME PLAIN TO HELP WITH THE-
WITH OUR AGE- LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS. PREPARE PLAN AND
WORK WITH THEIR JASON ENTITIES
IN THE REGION SO COME UP WITH
SOME REGIONAL PLANNING AND SOME
OF THIS IS HAPPENING
ORGANICALLY WHETHER YOU'RE- A-
FLOOD CONTROL DISTRICTS OTHER
ASSOCIATIONS TO GET TOGETHER
AND THEY- THEY TRY TO WORK.
COURTENEY INSTEAD ACROSS
COUNTIES AND TRIED TO LOOK AT
THE WHOLE REGION. BUT WE DON'T
HAVE A IN STATUTE OF
COORDINATED PLAN IN THE STATE'S
CURRENT MECHANISM FOR FUNDING
IT IS ADMITTEDLY PIECEMEAL
DEPENDING ON WHAT WE GET IN THE
BUDGET. AND THE COMPREHENSIVE
STRATEGY THIS WOULD BE
IMPORTANT TO MAKE SURE THAT OUR
INVESTMENTS ARE MADE THE MOST
EFFECTIVELY. AND RESILIENCY IS
OPTIMIZED SO THAT'S WHAT THIS
BILL DOES TO SIX TO FILL THE
GAP. BY DEVELOPING GUIDANCE FOR
PER STATE FEDERAL PRIVATE
INVESTMENT. IN FUNDING REGIONAL
PRIORITY ADAPTATION PROJECTS
ACROSS THE STATE AND ENCOURAGE
LOCAL REGIONAL ENTITIES TO.
COLLABORATE WHEN PLANNING FOR
CLIMATE ADAPTATION AND WAY TO
PROMOTES REGIONAL SOLUTIONS
AND- IMPROVES THE EFFECTIVENESS
AND EFFICIENCIES FOR ADAPTATION
PLANNING THIS IS. OUR HAS DONE
SOME WORK THE- DAY CLIMATE.
COLLABORATIVES HAVE SPRUNG UP
AT DIFFERENT LEVELS FOR
DIFFERENT LEVELS OF ENTHUSIASM
AND I WILL COMMENT THIS HAS
BEEN LED AT THE REGIONAL LEVEL
AND WE'VE BEEN FOLLOWING AND
THIS IS SORT OF TYING IT ALL UP
IN THE STATUTE SO WE HAVE MAKE
ARNOLD WITH VALLEY VISION AND
BRUCE WRITTEN WITH THE BAY AREA
CLIMATE ADAPTATION NETWORK. AND
AYE URGING AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT LET'S HEAR FROM YOUR
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. MAKE AND
BRUCE. THEY'RE BOTH ON THE
PHONE I HAVE A GOOD ACTORS HI
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS MATT
ARNOLD AND- YEP COMMITTEE CHAIR
ALLEN BUT YOU'RE BATES AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY
TODAY CREDIT AP TWENTY SIX
TWENTY ONE AND- I IMAGINE HE
COULD EITHER AND VALLEY VISION
WHICH IS A NON PROFIT RIGHT
HERE IN THE CAPITAL REGION IN
MY WORK IN TELEVISION I HAVE
BEEN AN ACTIVE LEADER OF ONE OF
THE REGIONAL COLLABORATIVES
THAT WERE JUST MENTION. DO YOU
NEED. THE CIVIC LADY CAPITAL
REGION CRIME ALREADY
COLLABORATIVE OR SEE OUR STATE.
WHERE I'VE BEEN INVOLVED IN
TWENTY FOURTEEN AND I CURRENTLY
SERVE AS ITS SHARE. IN THE
CAPITAL REGION ARE CLIMATE
RISK. CENTER ON EXTREME HEAT.
THIS WEEK WILDFIRE AND BOTH
DROUGHT AND FLOODS. AND OTHER
REGIONS OF THE STATE FACE
DIFFERENT REST. I'M ALL FOR THE
IMMEDIATE PAST CHAIR OF THE
STATEWIDE ALLIANCE A REGIONAL
COLLABORATIVES FOR CLIMATE
ADAPTATION OR PARK AT. WHICH IS
A COALITION OF SEVEN DIVERS
VOLUNTARY URBAN AND RURAL
NETWORK OF COMMUNITY LEADERS
AND PRIVATE PRACTITIONERS.
WHICH ALL WORK YOU CREATED
IMPLEMENT EFFECTIVE ADAPTATION
STRATEGIES TO BUILD REGIONAL
RESILIENCE TO CLIMATE IMPACTS.
TODAY BASED ON MY EXPERIENCE IN
ALL OF THIS AND ON BEHALF OF
VALUATION AND MYSELF. WITHOUT
DOUBT THE MOST SCALE FOR
CLIMATE ADAPTATION WORK IS
REGIONAL AT THE REGIONAL LEVEL
COLLISIONS ARE ABLE TO FAN
JURISDICTIONAL BOUNDARIES AS
THEY MUST DO. WHILE ALSO
RESPONDING TO REGIONAL CLIMATE
RISK AS THEY OFTEN DO. IF THE
CURRENT ECONOMIC CHALLENGES NOW
FACING LOCAL GOVERNMENTS WILL
GREATLY THREATEN THEIR ABILITY
TO CONDUCT ITS POTENTIAL
PLANNING. AB TWENTY SIX TWENTY
ONE WILL CREATE A DURABLE
FRAMEWORK FOR EFFECTIVE
ADAPTATION PLANNING AND ACTION.
IT WILL ALSO ENSURE THAT
NECESSARY FUTURE OR COUNTY
ALEX IN THAT. THE CENTRAL. AND
THAT BURST NATURE'S OF OUR
REGION. BASICALLY WE THAT
TWENTY TWENTY ONE FRAMEWORK
HELPS THAT THE COURT THREE LEGS
OF THE STOOL IS NECESSARY FOR
SUCCESSFUL REGIONAL ADAPTATION
WORK. FIRST LOCAL GOVERNMENT
CAPACITY INCREASING THE
CAPACITY OF LOCAL PLANNING
ENTITIES TO CONDUCT ITS
POTENTIAL MULTI AGENCY AND
MULTI JURISDICTION
COLLABORATION. SECOND REGIONAL
NETWORKS SUPPORTING AFRICAN
DIVERSE LOCAL AND REGIONAL
NETWORK HOLDERS TO PROVIDE
ACCESS INCLUSION TRANSPARENCY
AND ACCOUNTABILITY TO ANY
REGIONAL ADAPTATION PLANNING
PROCESS. AND THIRTY TECHNICAL
AND SCIENTIFIC CLIMATE
SERVICES. ACCORDING TO NEED FOR
OR LOCALLY APPROPRIATE LEVEL A
TECHNICAL AND APPLIED. SCIENCE
ADVICE FOR ADAPTATION THANK.
YOU TO THE ELEMENT THAT WE
BELIEVE WILL CONTRIBUTE TO
EFFECTIVE ADAPTATION RESPONSE
AND WE'RE PLEASED TO SEE THEM
BEING DEVELOPED. BY AB BY AB
TWENTY SIX TWENTY ONE AND
CREATE THAT THE. COURT THE BILL
AS A RESULT THANK YOU. OKAY BY
BRUCE REYES. GOOD AFTERNOON
CAROLINE COMMITTEE MEMBERS ARE
REASSURED NONE THE PROGRAM
DIRECTOR OF THE CLIENT READY OF
UC BERKELEY AND THE DIRECTOR OF
THE BAY AREA CLIMATE ADAPTATION
OF WORK AND WHAT SEEMS LIKE
MANY YEARS AGO A CO FOUNDER
STATEWIDE THE ARCHITECT BECAUSE
AFTERNOON IN SUPPORT OF THE V.
TWENTY SIX TWENTY ONE. WHY ARE
WE IMPORT WEALTH WE NEED VERY
MUCH A TRULY INTEGRATED
CALIFORNIA CLIMATE ADAPTATION
PROGRAM- I STRUCTURE THAT
BRINGS TOGETHER THIS WON'T BE
THE STATE AND REGIONAL AND
LOCAL RESOURCES IN THE MOST
COST EFFECTIVE AND POWERFUL
MANNER WE NEED REGIONAL PLANS
UP TO COORDINATE OUR ACTIONS
BECAUSE AS YOU KNOW T. MOBILE
RISING WILDFIRE EXTREME STORMS
AND ALL DON'T STOP AT THE
BOUNDARIES ARE COUNTY
BOUNDARIES WE ALSO NEED
REGIONAL PEER NETWORKS TO
SUPPORT AND INFORM THE-
PLANNING PROCESS AND- THAT'S
MAKE THAT REGIONALLY FOCUSED
ACTIONABLE SCIENCE TO GUIDE THE
WAY SO THAT'S WHY WE SUPPORT.
TWENTY SIX TWENTY ONE IN THE
EFFORT TO CREATE OUT OF
STRUCTURE OR- I'M MUCH BETTER
FORTY MORE HERE IN CALIFORNIA
THAT WILL PARTICULARLY FOCUS ON
IN MANY WAYS OUR MOST
IMPORTANTLY OUR ARMED CANNIBAL
COMMUNITIES. AS YOU KNOW. WE
CARBON EMISSIONS READ FOR LEAST
OUT YEARS SINCE WE HAVE AB TWO
THE DIDN'T HAPPEN WE- THAT IN.
AND LOOK GOVERNMENTS TO REACH
BODY TILL WITH THE ON ALL WE DO
THE RIGHT THING IT HAPPENED
BECAUSE WE GET CLEAR MY GOALS
WE HAVE STATE MAY. WE IDEA RE
AND LOCAL CLIMATE PROGRAMS AND
WE HAVE THE POTENTIAL FUNDING
FOR IMPLEMENTATION WE BELIEVE
IT'S TIME FOR CALIFORNIA'S
CLIMATE ADAPTATION PROGRAM TO
GROW UP IN A IN A SIMILAR WAY.
CALIFORNIA MONTHLY WE CAN
BECOME A GLOBAL LEADER ON
CLIMATE ADAPTATION RESILIENCE
AND- ALONG THE WAY WILL CREATE
THOUSANDS OF GOOD JOBS IN THE
PROCESS SO WE BELIEVE AB TWENTY
SIX TWENTY ONE WILL BE AN
IMPORTANT PART OF THIS MOVEMENT
FORWARD AND THANK YOU VERY MUCH
LET ME TALK ABOUT TODA THANKS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MR WRITTEN.
OKAY I DON'T KNOW HE- SEE
ANYONE ELSE IN THE GALLERY TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OR IN ROOM
ONE TWELVE. FIVE ARE THERE
ANYONE IS THERE ANYONE ON THE
ON THE PHONES- MODERATOR. TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
SIX TWENTY ONE. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN TO SHOW SUPPORT FOR
AB TWENTY SIX TWENTY ONE YOU
MAY PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AND FIRST OPEN MY NUMBER ONE
TWENTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS JUST
HIGHER BE WHO SPOKE ABOUT A
LEADERSHIP GROUP AND WE'RE
PROUD TO SUPPORT THE BILL THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME. EIGHTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN GOOD
AFTERNOON JUST KEEP ON COMING
UP IN CALGARY TALK ALLIANCE IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANKS. ONE
ONE SEVENTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
SURE THIS IS MARK BENJAMINS ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF RESOURCE
CONSERVATION DISTRICT. WELCOME
STATE TRACK. EIGHT ALL IN AB
TWENTY SIX POINT FIVE THANK YOU.
NINE ONE OH ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. REBECCA MARKETS ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA CLIMATE IN
AGRICULTURE NETWORK IN SUPPORT.
NINE ONE OH FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. SHARE MEMBERS MIKE
MULLIGAN YEAH YOU CESSATION OF
BAY AREA GOVERNMENTS IN THE
METROPOLITAN TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION I THANK MR MULLIN
FIRST EFFORTS IN THIS AREA AND
WE ARE IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN AS A
REMINDER TO SHOW SUPPORT FOR AB
TWENTY SIX TWENTY ONE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. SHOW SUPPORT FOR AB
TWENTY SIX TWENTY ONE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AND I HAVE NO ONE SHOWING
SUPPORT. AB TWENTY SIX TWENTY
ONE PLEASE CONTINUE. SO YOU'RE
SAYING WE SHOULD CONTINUE OR
OKAY. YES OKAY. OKAY GREAT OKAY
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU SO MUCH I
NOW WE GO TO OPPOSITION- WE
DON'T HAVE ANY. ONE WHO IS
REGISTERED TO PRESENT
OPPOSITION. WE CAN WE DON'T
HAVE ANY REGISTRAR POSITION THE
BILL THE- I DON'T KNOW ANYBODY
HERE IN THE CHAMBER OR IN ROOM
ONE TWELVE BUT- IS THERE
ANYBODY ON THE PHONE LINES-
MADAME MODERATOR. WHO WANTS TO
VOICE CONCERNS ARE OPPOSITION
AB TWENTY SIX TWENTY ONE.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN TO SHOW
OPPOSITION FOR AB TWENTY SIX
TWENTY ONE YOU MAY PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONE MOMENT
PLEASE. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE ONE ONE TWENTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH SORRY I WISH I WAS A
LITTLE TOO LATE I'M CALLING IN
SUPPORT MY NAME IS WOODY
HASTINGS WITH THE CLIMATE
CENTER IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
SIX TWENTY ONE. THANK YOU.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN I REMINDER
TO SHOW OPPOSITION FOR AB
TWENTY SIX TWENTY ONE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AT ZERO AT THE TIME.
TO SHOW OPPOSITION FOR AB
TWENTY SIX TWENTY ONE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. I HAVE NO ONE ELSE
SHOWING OPPOSITION THANK YOU SO
MUCH MEMORY APPRECIATE THAT
OKAY THE MEASURE IS NOW- BEFORE
THE COMMITTEE. FOR DISCUSSION.
I AM LOOKING OUT TO MY MEMBER I
CAN MOVE THE BILL MISGUIDED AND
OKAY SO CENTER HILL WANTS TO
MOVE THE BILL. AND WE HAVE
SOMEBODY. ON THE- COMPUTER WHO
WANTS TO SPEAK WHICH ONE I
DON'T. CENTER STERN STARING. IF
I IF I COULD MISTER CHAIR JUST
A QUESTION PLEASE. OKAY THANK
YOU- THANKS TO THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD. IT WE CAN I CAN'T
AFFORD IS TO SIT TIGHT WELL THE
CLIMATE CRISIS HITS US EVEN IF
WE'RE DEALING WITH COLLUDED TO
SAME TIME SO I DO APPRECIATE
THE URGENCY OF GETTING THESE
PLANNING EFFORTS GOING. I'M
TRYING TO TRYING TO GET
ASSISTANCE YOU JUST DON'T LIKE
WHAT THE WORK PRODUCT ITSELF IS
GONNA LOOK LIKE ADDED THESE
COLLABORATIVES AND HOW YOU SEE
THAT FITTING BACK INTO. THE
TOOLS THAT PR'S DEVELOPING WITH
THE- N. AND C. N. R. A. OR WITH
THE CLIMATE ASSESSMENT AND THE
SAFEGUARDING CALIFORNIA PLAN
LIKE HOW DO YOU SEE IT ALL
KINDA. FITTING TOGETHER IF YOU
WILL OKAY AND WHILE THE- AUTHOR
WHAT WHILE CENTER CASKEY MODELS
THAT QUESTION YOU NEED WE NEED
INTRODUCED JEREMY OF FORMERLY.
YES SO SENATOR HENRY STERN HERE
MY DISTRICT OFFICE HERE AT MY
DISTRICT DIRECTOR JEREMY WOLFE
THANK YOU FOR THE SENATE STERN
OKAY ONE EGG WILL HANDED OVER
TO THE CINEMA CASKEY TO. ATTACK
OUR FURNACE WITH THAT
IDENTIFICATION OF THE DISTRICT
STAFF ON. READY TO ANSWER THE
QUESTION THROUGH THE CHAIR. HI
I THINK. STILL IS IT IS I SEE
IT IN YOUR FAMILIAR WITH THE
FUNDING CHALLENGES THAT WE'VE
HAD IN THE SENATE- THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE RIGHT NOW THERE'S A-
IN EQUILIBRIUM NOT AN
EQUILIBRIUM IN THE DIFFERENT
COLLABORATORS AND HOW THEY'RE
WORKING SUMMER DOING A VERY
GOOD JOB OF. GETTING SOME OF
THE PLANNING MONEY OUT. SOME OF
THEM ARE NOT SO I THINK AT THE
FIRST TRANCHE IS GOING TO BE
IDENTIFYING HELPING THE
LOCALITIES THAT ARE READY TO DO
THAT THE PLANNING AND WORK IN A
COLLABORATIVE WAY. AND JUST THE
PLANNING DOLLARS- I THINK THE
OTHER THING IS SOME PEOPLE HAVE
A BIGGER PROBLEM SO THEY'RE
THEY'RE GOING TO NEED THAT
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND SOME
OF THEM JUST NEED THE- THE I
KNOW IN THE BAY AREA WE HAVE BC
DC THIS SORT OF. I WANT A
COOKIE CUTTER BUT THEY HAVE
THESE THAT. I HAVE IDENTIFIED
NEEDS TO GO THROUGH THE
PLANNING PROCESS TO TAKE. THEIR
ADDRESSED SVERAL ISSUES
WHETHER ITS- FIRES DROUGHT SEA
LEVEL RISE YEAH THE DATA DATA
SO I THINK THE FIRST I CAN'T
PROTECT ME THEY'RE GONNA COME
UP WITH. THEY'RE GONNA BE
TASKED WITH THE WITH THIS BUT I
THINK THE FIRST TRANCHE IS
GOING TO BE. ON THE PLANNING
AND SORT OF GETTING SOME
EQUILIBRIUM ON THE ONES THAT
ARE A LITTLE BIT BEHIND. VERSUS
THE ONES THAT AREN'T. WITH THAT
SAID NO SOME OF THE- SOME OF
THE COLLABORATIVES ARE AT THAT.
POINT WHERE THEY CAN IMPLEMENT
SOME THINGS AND THEY WANT TO
THEY WANT DAVID IDENTIFIED WITH
THE DEGREE TO WHICH THEY WANT
TO GET SOME INFORMATION DOLLARS
AND THAT'S GOING TO BE. PART OF
THE BUDGET PROCESS WHEN THEY
COME WITH US AND THEY SAY. WHAT
YOU GONNA DO I MEAN. BY WILL.
RECALL FOR. THE GOOD SENATOR
SHOULD RECALL. THE PARIS
CLIMATE CONFERENCE IN TWENTY
FIFTEEN WHICH WAS FIVE YEARS
AGO AT THAT TIME THE WORLD
COMMITTED SEVENTY PER. 17% OF
THEIR DOLLARS THE CLIMATE
ADAPTATION. YEAH WE PUT A 100%
INTIMIDATION SO WE'RE A LITTLE
BIT. NO WE'VE GOTTEN DRIBBLES
AND TRAVELS OF IT SO THIS IS A
FORMALIZATION OF THAT. I DON'T
THINK WE'RE GONNA GET TO
SEVENTEEN PERCENT- YOU KNOW IT
BUT THAT'S- BUT THAT'S- SEEMS
TO BE WHAT THE GOAL IS AND I
WOULD IMAGINE SOME OF THE
ADVOCATES WOULD SAY. MAKE IT
HAPPEN GIVE A 70% OF CAP AND
TRADE FOR. CLIMATE ADAPTATION
TO BE GREAT SO THAT'S I THINK
THAT'S THE FIRST. IMMEDIATE
MACINNES SAID AND BEING ABLE
TO. IDEAS INTEGRATED REGIONAL
PROPOSALS THAN TO HAVE THE
STATE DO SOME BACKSTOPPING AT
LEAST GET SOME SOMETHING MOVING
BECAUSE I KNOW. A LOT OF THE
COUNTIES ARE NOW STEPPING UP
TO. TAX THEMSELVES ARE TRYING
TO BOND THEMSELVES. BUT JUST
ASSUME THAT ALL THIS CAN BE
SOLVED THE LOCAL LEVEL I THINK
MISSES THE- MISSES THE MARK ON
THE SALE OF THE PROBLEM SO. I'M
NOT AS YET HAPPY TO SUPPORT THE
BILL IN APPRECIATE YOU BRING
AFFORD AND- LOOK FOR TO. TRY TO
GET A REALLY GOOD INTEGRATED
PRO SO THAT. LOCALS ARE MOVING
AT THE SAME TIME THE STATE'S
GET READY AND WE GET. HOPEFULLY
LIKE YOU SAID SOME ACTUAL
DOLLARS COMMITTED THIS WAY
MISTER CHAIR I KNOW THAT A-
HILL HIS WILL BE A BENEFICIARY
DISCERNS A PROJECT GOING ON
RIGHT NOW ON THE ALAMEDA CREEK.
IN THE BAY AREA IT'S THE
LARGEST RIVER THAT GOES INTO
SAN FRANCISCO BAY AND IT'S
BASICALLY. REWORKING THE WEAPON
THE RIVER SO YOU TAKE OUT THE
CEMENT AND YOU LET THE- THE
SOIL. SPREAD OUT TO THE REST OF
THE BAY THE ANTICIPATED
BIOLOGICAL WORK IS AT ONCE
THAT'S COMPLETED THAT'S GOING
TO HAVE THE EQUIVALENT OF
COMPROMISING FOR ONE FOOT OF
SEA LEVEL RISE AND THERE'S SOME
AREAS IN FOSTER CITY OR EAST
PALO ALTO THEY ARE IN. THE
LOCALE OF ALAMEDA CREEK BUT
THAT WOULD SET DOWNTOWN SAN
FRANCISCO WILL BENEFIT AND THE
AIRPORT IF YOU IF YOUACTUALLY
MITIGATE FOR THAT AND THAT IS
ONE OF THESE. PIECES OF WORK
THAT'S GOING ON SIMULTANEOUSLY
THE PLAN AND THEY JUST HAPPEN
TO BE A HEAD ON THE PLANET SOME
MORE ACTIVELY SOME MONEY CAME
IN FROM THE CITY CALIFORNIA
FROM I DON'T KNOW HOW IT
HAPPENED. RECALL THAT THAT IS
WHO IS GOING TO BE A SHOWCASE
AND THAT'S ANOTHER THING THAT
OPR. IN THE ADVOCATES IN THE
COLLABORATIVE GOING TO DO IS
THEY'RE GOING TO SHARE THESE
BEST PRACTICES AND THAT WOULD
BE. I THINK STEP TO IN THIS. IS
PAT AND WHAT THAT ORIGINAL VOTE.
THIRTY CENTER. OKAY I'M GOING
BACK TO SEE IF ANYONE HAS
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS. OKAY
THANK YOU THANK YOU SET UP I'LL
TAKE THAT AS YOUR CLOTHES- I
THINK YOU'RE YOU'RE SPOT ON-
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL ZERO. I
DON'T NUMBER THREE AB TWENTY
SIX TWENTY ONE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MULLIN THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE ALLEN HI ALLEN AYE
BATES. NOT LOADING PAGE NOT
VOTING DALLY. DALY NO HELLO HI
HILL HI. SKINNER SKINNER BOB HI
SKINNER AYE STERN. HI STERN HI
MY CASKEY HI MY CASKEY OKAY
WARNING. GUYS YEAH YEAH FIVE TO
ONE OKAY SETS FIVE TO ONE- IMAC
I GUESS WE CLOSER ON THAT. SB
CLOSER ON THAT OKAY THANK YOU
THANK YOU MEMBERS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ALL RIGHT THIS BRINGS
US TO OUR FINAL. BOB DON'T KNOW
MY GOD NO NOT OUR FINAL BILL. I
WAS GETTING EXCITED. AB TWENTY
SEVEN THIRTY ONE IS NEXT TODD
GLORIA THIS BILL. YOU MAY PUT
IN A- BAG OR PURSE THE DICE AND
WE'RE WE'RE HAPPY TO HAVE YOU
HERE. ON THE RED CARPET.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER I'M HAPPY TO BE
HERE MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME THAT IF
YOU'RE COMMITTEE COLLEAGUES I
TO THE PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY SEVEN THIRTY ONE. I
BELIEVE A BILL THAT I BELIEVE
WILL BE TRANSFORMATIONAL FROM
MY HOMETOWN IN THE ENTIRE CITY
GO REGION. OR SERVICE CHAIRMAN
BY TAKING YOU AND YOUR STAFF
AND MANY MANY HOURS OF WORK
THAT YOU'VE PUT IN ON THIS
BILL. I THANK YOU FOR
COOPERATING THE ADDITIONAL
AUTHORS AMENDMENT AS NOTED IN
THE ANALYSIS AND A COMIC NUMBER
TWENTY SEVEN THIRTY ONE IS
INTENDED TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF A
UNIQUE OPPORTUNITY. FOR OUR
LOCAL TRANSFER. AGENCY SANDAG
TO PARTNER WITH THE UNITED
STATES NAVY. ON IMPORTANT
REDEVELOPMENT PROJECT IN SAN
DIEGO. FIRST AND FOREMOST THIS
BILL WILL STRENGTHENS THE
NAVY'S PRESENCE. AMERICA'S
FINEST CITY. UNLIKE OTHER NAVY
INFRASTRUCTURE THE NAV OR
FACILITY WHICH HOUSES THE NAVY
CYBER SECURITY. PROFESSIONALS
DOES NOT REQUIRE PROXIMITY TO
THE WATER. WE'RE HOPEFUL THAT
THIS BILL WILL MAINTAIN SAN
DIEGO AS A CROWD. IN STRONG
EIGHTY TERABYTE COURAGE IN THE
NAVY TO KEEP THESE JOBS AT THE
SITE. WITH SEVERAL ADDITIONAL
COMMUNITY BENEFITS. EQUALLY
IMPORTANT IS BILL CONSULTED THE
CONSTRUCTION. OF A CENTRAL
MOBILITY TRANSIT HUB. TO
CONNECT DIFFERENT TRANSIT
ROUTES AT ONE PLACE. ALONG WITH
A TRANSIT ORIENTED DEVELOPMENT
OF DESPERATELY NEEDED NEW
HOUSING. COMMERCIAL AND RETAIL
SPACES. AND FINALLY THIS BILL
WILL FINALLY ALLOW US TO
CONNECT. OUR INTERNET. AIR WITH
OUR LIGHT RAIL SYSTEM. AS
ANALYSIS NOTES THE NAY IS INTO
ENVIRONMENT REVIEW FOR THE
REDEVELOPMENT OF THE OLD TOWN
SITE. IT HAS CONDUCTED SEVERAL
PUBLIC WORKSHOPS ACCEPTING AND
SOLICITING INPUT. N. AS
EXPECTED RECORD OF DECISION IS
EXPECTED IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
THE PROVISIONS OF THIS BILL ARE
NARROWLY CRAFTED HELP KEEP THE
MOBILITY HUB AS A POSSIBLE
ALTERNATIVE. SO LET ME GIVE YOU
COVER THE QUICK PROVISIONS OF
THIS BILL S. TWENTY SEVEN
THIRTY ONE ALLOW SANDAG TO USE
THE NAVY'S ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACT
STATEMENT AS THE BASIS OF ITS
ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW. SO LONG
AS IT MEETS THE TECHNICAL RIGOR
OF DOVE SEQUEL E. I. R. I WOULD
NOTE THAT THIS PROVISION IS
INTENDED TO STRENGTHEN THE
ENVIRONMENT A VIEW THAT THE
NAVY. HAS TO UNDERTAKE THIS
BILL WILL PROVIDE A TWO AND
SEVEN DAY EXPEDITED REVIEW THE
SAME AMOUNT OF TIME HAS BEEN
PROPOSED FOR SEVERAL SPORTS
ARENAS. FOR THE CENTRAL
MOBILITY HUB ONLY AND FINALLY
THIS BILL ESTABLISHES SEVERAL
PROCEDURES FOR PUBLIC
PARTICIPATION SAID THAT MUST
UNDERTAKE INCLUDING HOLDING
PUBLIC WORKSHOPS PROVIDING IN
THE MIDDLE DOCUMENTS
ELECTRONICALLY. AND MEDIATION
PROCEDURES. EXCHANGE FOR THIS
ACCOMMODATION THIS BILL
PROPOSED SEVERAL IMPORTANT
CONDITIONS ON THIS PROPERTY
THESE ARE IMPORTANT. ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY SEVEN THIRTY ONE
THERE IS THE SITE PLAN MEET US
25% VMT REDUCTION BELOW THE
REGIONAL AVERAGE. BILL REQUIRE
SENSIBILITY HAD TO OBTAIN LEGAL.
EDUCATION THIS BILL RECOGNIZES
THAT THE PROJECT CAN BE
GREENHOUSE GAS NEUTRAL WITH AN
EMPHASIS ON POLIZISTEN. THERE'S
AND THIS REQUIRES THE YOU S. K.
IN PAIN WORKFORCE. THE STATE'S
SECOND LARGEST CITY AND PROVIDE
SOME OF THE DESPERATELY NEEDED
STIMULUS FOR OUR LOCAL ECONOMY
THAT IS SUFFERING DUE TO THE
EFFECTS OF COVINA. WITH THE
NEED AND THE WITHOUT THE NEED
OF ADDITIONAL STATE FUNDING. ON
BEHALF OF THE SENATE PRESIDENT
PRO TEM TONI ATKINS OF MYSELF I
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE THIS
AFTERNOON WITH ME ON THE PHONE
TODAY TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
ISRAMCO HEAD. DIRECTOR SPECIAL
PROJECTS WITH SANDBAGS AND MARK
PALMER EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
THE SAN DIEGO MILITARY ADVISORY.
POSSIBILITIES THE MAC I WANT TO
OR IF IT DOES THANK YOU YOUR
FIRST MISTER CAR. BOTH OF.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY OR FOR ALL
THREE THIS LET. IN FUTURE ALLEN
SENATORS FOR YOUR TIME TODAY.
AND THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER SEE.
HANDING AND COLOR WITH THE
NEEDY TO READ AND NOW WORKS ARE
YOU SICK OR SICK COME. UNDER
THIS PARTNERSHIP WOULD. A TREND.
CENTRAL HOW. THAT WOULD CONNECT
CURRENT AND FUTURE OF THREE
PUBLIC TRANSIT. IN THE SAME TO
YOUR- IN PROVIDE DIRECTOR CAN
TO THE DIEGO AIRPORT. HE IS
CURRENTLY UNDER FEDERAL
JURISDICTION THIS BILL WILL
INCENTIVIZE THE NEED TO PARTNER
WITH SANDAG. PROVIDING
FRAMEWORK TO BRING THE PROJECT
INTO SEQUEL- IN TACKLE
IMPORTANT REGIONAL AND
STATEWIDE GOALS AS PART OF
THEIR PROJECT. NEEDLESS TO SAY
THIS PROJECT IS THE PRODUCT OF
MANY HOURS OF WORK BY STAFF AT
SANDAG. THE CITY OF SAN DIEGO
IN THE NAVY WE ARE EXCITED TO
HAVE THE STATE OF THE PARTNER
IN THIS PROJECT. AND THANK YOU
AGAIN. FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT AT YOUR COMMITTEE. OKAY
THANK YOU. I DON'T THINK I WANT
TO THANK YOU BY THE WAY RIGHT
AND WHAT WE OBVIOUSLY- GOT
CHANCE TO CHAT AND WE SHOULD
ALL THE WORK ITS INDEX IN DOING
ON THIS- COULD BE REALLY
EXCITING REALLY EXCITING
PROJECT FOR THE WHOLE REGION
I'M MARK PALMER LET'S HEAR FROM
YOU NEXT FROM THE MILITARY
BUDGET COUNCIL. MILITARY HOW
MANY TO EXPECT TO GET WORKSHOPS
AND THE FIRST. MISTER MISTER
BOMBER IS HE- GLOBAL AND THEN
THE OTHER YES CAN YOU HEAR ME
THE AREA WE CAN HEAR YOU NOW
SOME OTHER. CAN YOU HEAR ME YES
YES WE CAN HEAR YOU LOUD AND
CLEAR. OKAY SIR THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THIS LEGISLATION BY
MARK PALMER EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF THE SAN DIEGO MILITARY
ADVISORY COUNCIL. NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION ESTABLISHED
SIXTEEN YEARS AGO TO BE A
STRONG ADVOCATE ON BEHALF OF
THE MILITARY THEIR FAMILIES AND
VETERANS IN THE SAN DIEGO
REGION. WE WORK VERY CLOSELY
WITH OUR MILITARY AND OUR
REGION. OUR ADVOCACY EFFORTS
INCLUDING WORKING WITH OUR
COMMUNITY BUSINESS LEADERS AND
ELECTED OFFICIALS TO IMPROVE
THEIR UNDERSTANDING OF THE
IMPORTANT CONTRIBUTIONS MADE BY
THE MILITARY. THE SAN DIEGO
MILITARY ATTACK BY THREE
COUNCIL PRODUCES THE ANNUAL
MILITARY ECONOMIC IMPACT
REPORT. INDEPENDENTLY DOCUMENTS
THE POSITIVE IMPACT FROM THE
DEFENSE BUDGET AND MILITARY
PERSONNEL PAYING COMPENSATION
WHAT ARE LOCAL AND. STATE
ECONOMY. LORD SHOWS THAT MORE
THAN THREE HUNDRED AND THOUSAND
JOBS ARE TIED TO THE DEFENSE
BUDGET IN THE SAN DIEGO REGION.
AND ACCOUNTS FOR MORE THAN 20%
OF OUR GROSS REGIONAL PRODUCT.
THAT'S TWENTY EIGHT BILLION
DOLLARS IN DIRECT DEFENSE
SPENDING MORE THAN FIFTY
BILLION DOLLARS IMPACT ON OUR
LOCAL ECONOMY. LAST YEAR A
REORT FOCUSED ON THE NAV WAR
HEADQUARTERS AND DOCUMENTED
THEIR FIVE THOUSAND JOBS AT THE
HEADQUARTERS IN MORE THAN
TWENTY SIX THOUSAND JOBS IN OUR
AREA BETTER HI TO THE PRESENCE
OF THIS HEAD QUARTER.
CALIFORNIA IS A TOP STATE
RECEIVING CONTRACTS FROM NOW
BEFORE RECEIVING MORE THAN ONE
POINT SEVEN BILLION OF THE
COMMANDS FIVE BILLION DOLLARS
IN SPENDING THEIR PRESENCE HERE
IS CRITICAL TO OUR ECONOMY. THE
REDEVELOPMENT WILL KEEP THIS
WORK HERE AND ENABLE
CONSIDERABLE GROWTH THE
REDEVELOPMENT MEANS GOOD JOBS
WITHOUT THE NEED FOR ANY STATE
FUNDS. WE'D LIKE TO THANK
ASSEMBLY TODD GLORIA FOR
SPONSORING THIS BILL IN HIS
LEADERSHIP IN HELPING KEEP THE
NETWORK FACILITY IN CALIFORNIA
PRESERVING THE MANY JOBS
DIRECTLY AND INDIRECTLY
ASSOCIATED WITH THIS VITAL
MILITARY HI TECH MAN. WE ALSO
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
SANDAG ONE IS ONE OF A KIND
WORLD CLASS PROJECT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH.
LET'S NOW OPEN UP. THE LINES
FOR- FOR TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT
AT BECAUSE I DON'T SEE ONE
PRESENT EITHER HERE IN THE
GALLERY OR IN ROOM ONE TWELVE
SO A MODERATOR IS THERE ANYONE
WHO WANTS TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL AB TWENTY SEVEN
THIRTY ONE ON OUR PHONE LINES.
SURE IF YOU ARE IMPORTANT AB
TWENTY SEVEN THIRTY ONE YOU MAY
NOW PRESS ONE THEN IS ZERO.
THAT IS IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
SEVEN THIRTY ONE ONE. SEVEN
ZERO. AND WE WILL GO TO THE
LINE OF ONE TWENTY SEVEN. YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN THANK THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
THIS IS MORE RED HOT ON BEHALF
OF SAN DIEGO MAYOR AND THE FULL
CITY COUNCIL IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF THE BILL. A STATEMENT ABOUT
THE COMPONENT IS INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT TO US BUT- THE
TRANSIT HUB THAT WE TALKED
ABOUT. I WILL HELP US MEET OUR
CLIMATE ACTION AND CALLS IN THE
CITY AND WE STRONGLY SUPPORTED
AND NURTURE I THOUGHT TODAY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU IF YOU ARE
IN PART OF AB TWENTY SEVEN AND
THIRTY ONE THAT IS ONE AND THEN
IS THERE AT THIS TIME. ONE
ZERO. WE DO NOT HAVE ANYONE IN
Q. OKAY. THANK YOU SO MUCH
APPRECIATE. TURN TO OPPOSITION
IF ANYONE WANTS TO VOICE
CONCERNS ABOUT THE BILL I WE
DON'T HAVE ANYONE REGISTERED TO
TESTIFY HERE AT THE HEARING IN
OPPOSITION- BUT CERTAINLY IF
THERE'S ANYBODY. WHO'S ON THE
PHONE LINE- WHO WANTS IT TO
REGISTER THEIR OPPOSITION WE
WOULD LOVE TO HEAR FROM THEM.
DEFINITELY IF YOU WERE IN
OPPOSITION OF EIGHTEEN TWENTY
SEVEN THIRTY ONE YOU MAY PRESS
ONE THEN IF ZERO NOW. THAT IS
ONE IT VERY THOROUGH IN
OPPOSITION OF AB. TWENTY SEVEN
THIRTY ONE. THERE IS NO ONE IN
Q. IN OPPOSITION OKAY. THANK
YOU SO MUCH THE MATTER IS NOW
BEFORE THE COMMITTEE FOR
DISCUSSION DEBATE. I AM LOOKING
AT THE MEMBERS I SEE- ASSEMBLY
CASKEY IS WAVING HIS HAND.
MISTER CARROLL MAKE IT QUICK
SINCE I DO SIT ON THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE IN A NORMAL WORLD
THIS WOULD BE REFERRED THERE I
NOTED TO JUDICIAL THE JUDGES
HAVE. OBJECTED TO I WILL NOTE
THAT I IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING
THAT WE'RE GOING TO COMMITTEE.
THE AUTHORS GOING TO AMEND THE
BILL TO ALLOW THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL FORM TO BE THE GIVEN
ANOTHER SIX MONTHS TO MAKE THE
M. AMENDMENTS ON. THE RULES OF
THE COURT. WITH THAT SAID I
KNOW THAT THERE'S OTHER
AMENDMENTS ARE GOING IN- IT'S
NOT IT SHOULD BE NOTED THAT.
CREATING THE RECORD
SIMULTANEOUSLY AS THEY'RE GOING
THROUGH THIS. PROCESS WHICH
WITH ALL THE BENEFITS OF A
SEQUEL PROCESS WHICH IS ONE OF
THE THINGS. I WILL NOTE IT SAID
IF WE DID NOTHING IF WE WEREN'T
DEALING WITH THIS BILL THE NAVY
WOULD JUST GO THROUGH THEIR
NEED FOR PROGRESS DEVELOP IT
AND DO WHATEVER THEY WANT. SO
WE'RE- WE'RE IN THE GENRE OF
SEQUEL EXEMPTIONS WERE TAKING.
THIS BILL WE'RE GIVING THE TWO
HUNDRED SEVENTY DAYS ALTHOUGH
WHICH TWO HUNDRED SEVENTY
BUSINESS DAYS AND THEY'VE GOT
TO DO WITH THE- LEGISLATION
GETS SAYS COULD BE A STATUS
CONFERENCE TO TRY TO TIGHTEN UP
DEAD. DEAD COURT AREA- WITH
THAT IN THE COMMENTS FROM THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE I THINK
THAT. THE ON BALANCE THE
LEGISLATION. LAWRENCE THIS
CONSIDER THIS CONSIDERATION I
THINK THAT THEY ARE THE I'D
LIKE TO UNDERSCORE THE SEAPORT
VALUE THAT SANDY HAVE HAS
NEGOTIATED EDITION WITH
HEARINGS IN THE PUBLIC INPUT.
FAR GREATER THAN NAY FOR FAR
GREATER THAN THE NAVY WOULD
HAVE TO DO IS BENEFIT FOR THE
PROJECT ON THE NAVY SIDE A NAVY
SAID THAT WE WOULD HAVE NO
POWER. INPUT AND THEY'RE
STANDING WITH THAT SAID. IT
DOES SEEM LIKE THERE'S A-
LIMITED TIME THIS IS
CONSTRUCTED HERE TO REALLY
PROVIDE AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
TRANSIT TO GET FINALLY GET
INTO. THE SAN DIEGO AIRPORT BUT
ALSO THAT THAT CAN ACTIVITY
WITH THE ADDITIONAL- PARTS OF
THE COUNTRY APART TO THE CITY
AND THAT IN THE 25% GOAL OF
INCREASING TRANSIT I WISH THAT
WERE IN OTHER SEQUEL EXEMPTION
BILLS HAVE COME BEFORE BEFORE
THIS COMMITTEE- SO WITH THAT
I'M PREPARED TO ACTUALLY MOVE
THIS BILL AND- WANT TO COMMEND
THE STAFF ONCE AGAIN FOR A
GREAT NOW SAYS. THANK YOU THANK
YOU CENTER FROM THE FAR REACHES
THE NORTHEASTERN CORNER OF OUR
CHAMBER. REPRESENTING THE
NORTHEASTERN PART OF THE STATE
THAT'S RIGHT WE HAVE SENATE
DOLLARS HEY AT WHAT WOULDN'T
JUST QUESTION OF THE AUTHOR
REAL QUICK WHEN DO YOU EXPECT
TO BE TAKING THOSE- AMENDMENT
TO BETWEEN NOW AND APPROACH OR-
WELL ON THAT. I'VE DONE A LOT
OF WORK IN THE AREA OF. IPAA
AND SEEK WERE DOING FORESTRY
PROJECTS IN OUR COMMUNITIES
OVERLYING WITH STATE. WHAT IS
THAT THE ANTICIPATION. THAT THE
CHAIR OF A PERFORATIONS EARLIER
TODAY TRYING TO FIGURE OUT WHAT
THE MOST ELEGANT SOLUTION WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK ON THIS NOT
JUST FOR THE ISSUES RAISED BY
SENATOR- BUT BY ISSUES OF A
BASED IN SOME LETTERS WE
RECEIVE JUST LAST NIGHT. WELL
I'M GONNA LET OFF THE BILL
UNTIL I SEE THOSE AND THEN.
SOUNDS LIKE WE MIGHT BE ABLE TO
GET THERE AND THEN. WHEN IT
COMES BACK TO THE FLOOR THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. OKAY. OKAY I
RIGHT ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
THOUGHTS IN THE COMMITTEE.
SEAMAN LET'S LET ME LET YOU
CLOSE. I'LL JUST BE VERY
SUCCINCT AND SAFER STUFF AGAIN
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN FOR
YOUR- PARTNERSHIP IN GETTING
THIS BILL INTO A CONDITION THAT
I THINK IS WORTHY OF THIS
COMMITTEE SUPPORT I STAND
BEFORE YOU AS A NATIVE SAN
DIEGO PROUD OF THIS PIECE OF
LEGISLATION THANK GOD IT WAS
JUST A FEW BLOCKS FROM THE SITE
I'M PERSONALLY INTERESTED IN
MAKING SURE THAT WE DO
SOMETHING WORLD CLASS ON THIS
SITE AS SENATOR WHITE HOUSE YOU
MENTION THE NAVY COULD MOVE
FORWARD AND DO WHATEVER IT
WANTS THE FACT THAT THEY'RE
SERVING AS PARTNERS WITH THE
BROADER COMMUNITY TO SAY THAT
WE'RE GOING TO. SET A HIGHER
STANDARD AND WE'RE GONNA
PROVIDE A COMMUNITY BENEFIT IN
THE FORM OF A RETAIL
TRANSPORTATION HUB THAT WE SO
DESPERATELY NEED IN ORDER TO
MEET OUR CLIMATE ACTION PLAN
GOALS I THINK THIS IS A HOME
RUN I HOPE THE COMMITTEE AGREES
AS WELL AND AGAIN I APPRECIATE
YOUR CONSIDERATION THIS
AFTERNOON THANK YOU OKAY WHY
DON'T WE CALL THE ROLL CONSUME.
I AM NUMBER FOUR. A TWENTY
SEVEN THIRTY ONE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GLORIA THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE ALLEN BY ALLEN AYE
BATES. HI NOT BUILDING BATES
NOT VOTING. DALLY NOT VERY
DALLY NOT VOTING HILL BY HILL
HI SKINNER. SKINNER HI SKINNER
AYE STERN. STERN AYE STERN HI
MY COUNTY LINE. BURKE OWSKI I'D-
GOOD JOB OKAY FIVE ZERO FIVE
ZERO CLOSE THE ROLE ON AB
TWENTY SEVEN THIRTY ONE. LET'S
NOW GO TO ITEM FIVE. THIS IS
SERRA RIVAS IS AB TWENTY NINE
FIFTY FOUR. YOU MAY PROCEED
WHEN READY.
GOOD AFTERNOON
SENATORS LIKE TO THINK THAT
SHARING COMMITTEE STAFF FOR-
OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE THIS
AFTERNOON. PLEASE TO PRESENT
ASSEMBLY BILL TWO NINE FIVE
FOUR. LEGISLATION THAT WOULD
DIRECT THE CALIFORNIA AIR
RESOURCES BOARD TO INCORPORATE
AND SET IN OVERALL CLIMATE GOAL
FOR OUR STATE'S NATURAL AND
WORKING LANDS. NATURAL ECONOMIC
PRIZE OVER 90% OF CALIFORNIA'S
DIVERSE INCREDIBLE LANDSCAPE.
THIS INCLUDES FORESTS
RANGELANDS FARMS WETLANDS AND
MORE. AND THESE LANDS HAVE THE
POTENTIAL TO SEQUESTER.
SIGNIFICAN AMOUNTS OF CARBON N.
AS A YOU ON THOUGH UNDER
CALIFORNIA'S LANDMARK
ENVIRONMENTAL LAW ASSEMBLY BILL
THIRTY TWO. THE CALIFORNIA AIR
RESOURCES BOARD IS REQUIRED TO
DEVELOP A SCOPING PLAN. A PLAN
MAPPING OUT POSSIBLE
APPROACHES. THAT OUR STATE CA
TAKE TO REDUCE GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS AND ME TO THE STATE'S
EMISSION REDUCTION TARGETS.
UPDATED EVERY FIVE TO SEVEN
YEARS THE SCOPING PLAN IS NON
BINDING AND NON REGULATORY.
IT'S SIMPLY LAYS OUT POSSIBLE
OPTIONS FOR OUR STATE TO
ACHIEVE ITS CLIMATE GOALS. AND
IN PREPARATION FOR NEXT YEAR'S
SCOPING PLAN UPDATE THIS
LEGISLATION. WILL ENSURE THAT
THE AIR RESOURCES BOARD FULLY
FULLY CONSIDER AND LEVERAGE THE
CONSIDERABLE POWER AND
POTENTIAL OF OUR STATE NATURAL
AND WORKING LANDS AS WE
CONTINUE TO WORK TOWARDS
ACHIEVING OUR STATEWIDE
EMISSION REDUCTION GOALS. AND
POSSIBLY. AB ONE DAY ACHIEVE AN
ECOLOGICAL BALANCE A BALANCE
BETWEEN OUR CARBON EMISSIONS
AND PROCESSES OR OR METHODS
THAT REDUCE THE IMPACT OF THAT.
OF THESE EMISSIONS. AND SO
CLIMATE SCIENTISTS LEADING
RESEARCHERS FROM AROUND THE
WORLD AGREE WE HAVE TO DO MORE
WE HAVE TO MAXIMIZE METHODS TO
CAPTURE CARBON. UTILIZING OUR
NATURAL WORKING LANDS IF WE ARE
GOING TO FEND OFF THE WORST
IMPACTS OF CLIMATE CHANGE.
CLEARLY THERE IS NO SILVER
BULLET WHEN IT COMES TO
REMOVING CO TWO FROM THE
ATMOSPHERE NO SINGLE TECHNOLOGY
OR METHOD EXISTS. TO PROVIDE
ALL THE CO TWO REMOVAL THAT IS
REQUIRED. THERE IS OBVIOUS NEED
FOR ADDITIONAL RESEARCH WHEN IT
COMES TO CARBON REMOVAL BUT A
LARGE BODY OF EVIDENCE HAS MADE
IT VERY CLEAR. NAPOL WORKING
LANDS INTERVENTIONS HAVE THE
POTENTIAL TO CONTRIBUTE
SIGNIFICANTLY. TO WHAT IS
PERHAPS THE MOST PRESSING ISSUE
OF OUR TIME. AGAIN THIS UP
SCORES ARE NEED TO FULLY
LEVERAGE THE POTENTIAL OF OUR
NATURAL AND WORKING LANDS IN
OUR CLIMATE CONVERSATION. BEST
PRACTICES FOR SEQUESTERING
RECOVERING CARBON A RELATIVELY
INEXPENSIVE AND THEY'RE
AVAILABLE TO US NOW. THESE
NATURAL SOLUTIONS A CLOUD
MANAGEMENT RESTORATION OF
WOODLANDS AND WETLANDS AND
RESTORING AND ENRICHING SOILS
IN ADDITION TO PROVIDING
IMPROVEMENTS TO OUR WATER AND
AIR QUALITY. ATTENTION WE
HIGHER YIELDS FOR AGRICULTURE
LAND CONSERVATION AND WILDFIRE
PREVENTION. I SHOULD NOTE THAT
NATURAL WORKING LANDS POLICIES
PRACTICES OR PROGRAMS ARE
NOTHING NEW TO OUR STATE THE
NOTHING NEW TO CALIFORNIA. AS
WE STATED AS WAS STATED IN A
PREVIOUS ANALYSIS BY THE
COMMITTEE. EFFORTS TO ENHANCE
CARBON CAPTURE THROUGH OUR
NATURAL WORKING LANDS HAVE BEEN
DONE ON A PROJECT BY PROJECT
BASIS. AND OUR STATE HAS YET TO
HAVE AN OFFICIAL OVERARCHING
PLAN TO OR LEAD AGENCY TO
COORDINATE A COHESIVE STRATEGY
AROUND OUR NATURAL WORKING
LANDS. LET'S KEEP IN MIND IF
YOU'RE SCOPING PLAN. PROJECTED
THAT STATE LED EFFORTS TO
CAPTURE. CARBON FROM NATURAL
AND WORKING LANDS COULD RESULT
IN THE IMAGE REDUCTIONS OF UP
OF ABOUT THIRTY SIX MILLION
METRIC TONS OF CARBON BY TWENTY
FORTY FIVE. WHICH IS EQUIVALENT
TO TAKING UP TO EIGHT MILLION
EIGHT MILLION PASSENGER CARS
OFF THE ROAD. WE HAVE REACHED
THE POINT IN THIS CLIMATE
CRISIS WHERE WE MUST DEVELOP
PATHWAYS TO REMOVE CARBON FROM
THE ATMOSPHERE. AND THIS
LEGISLATION HELPS GET US THERE
BY ENSURING THAT WE COLLABORATE
AND IDENTIFY STRATEGIES TO
INTEGRATE OUR NATURAL AND
WORKING LANDS AS ASSETS. IN OUR
FIGHT AGAINST CLIMATE CHANGE.
AGAIN THE SCOPING PLAN IS NON
BINDING. IT IS NON REGULATORY.
NON BINDING NON REGULATORY IT
SIMPLY MAPS OUT POSSIBLE
PATHWAYS TO REACH OUR STATE'S
CLIMATE TARGETS. THAT THE
LEGISLATURE AND RELEVANT
AGENCIES CAN CONSIDER IN THE
YEARS AHEAD SO WITH THAT MISTER
SHARP. THANK YOU RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE AND WITH US
VIA PHONE IS WE SHOP FOR
SEVERAL OF THE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA CLIMATE CHANGE
PROGRAM FOR THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY. AND G. N. MERYL
THE POLICY FOR THE CALIFORNIA
CLIMATE AND AGRICULTURAL
NETWORK THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
THANK YOU THANKS VERY MUCH OUR
LET'S HEAR FIRST FROM
MISPERCEPTION. YEAH THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND GOOD AFTERNOON
MICHELLE PASSERO AND DIRECT
THAT CALIFORNIA CLIMATE PROGRAM
AT THE NATURE CONSERVANCY. I
LIKE TO TAKE THE CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK ON
IMPORTANT TOPIC INTENSELY
DURING CHALLENGING TIMES.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER READ AT FIRST
LEADERSHIP ON THIS IMPORTANT
TOPIC. NOW MORE THAN EVER WE
NEED NATURE FOR PUBLIC HEALTH
AND THE HEALTH OF OUR CLIENT.
THIS BILL HELP ADVANCE BOTH OUT
FROM AS WELL AS OTHER IMPORTANT
BENEFITS. THEY'RE NUMBER OF
PUBLISHED SCIENTIFIC ANALYSES
INCLUDING SEVERAL THAT THE
NATURE CONSERVANCY AND PUBLISH.
KATE ACTION BY URBAN FORESTRY
WORK RESTORATION AND FIRE RISK
REDUCTION LAND CONSERVATION IN
A VARIETY OF PLAN. IT IS AN
ACTIVITY. ONLY CONTRIBUTE TERM
TERM. YOUR GIFT CARD THE M. AND
ALTHOUGH ACT COMMUNITIES FROM
CRIME IN. LIKE FIRE. HEAT
UTILIZING WAS. NEVER THE PAST
DECADE THERE HAD BEEN
SIGNIFICANT WORK ACROSS THE
STATE INCLUDING ACROSS AGENCIES
ON TOPICS. FROM GREENHOUSE GAS
INVENTORY ESTIMATING THE
REDUCTION POTENTIAL ARE NOT TO
WORKING LAND ACCOUNTING
METHODS. I DON'T FIND A RANGE
OF BENEFITS THAT WOULD RESULT
FROM KIND ACTION. ACTOR BUT NOT
A NEW. ISSUE OR AN- DESPITE ALL
THE WORK CLEAR CLIMATE IN
COORDINATED WITH ACTION LIKE
HAVE AND OTHER FACTORS ARE
MISSING. AND IT STILL IS IN
CATALYST EXACTLY ISSUE. AT THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS THAT THEIR
RIGHTS LEGISLATOR LEADERSHIP ON
THE ISSUE RECOGNIZE THE NOT
WORK IN THE ARE YOU THANKS PART
OF ME DAY GOAL CLINICAL.
ADVANCES IN CO WITH A CLEAR
LEAD. IT'S PRETTY CRITICAL FOR
YOU CONFUSION AND CRIED. FORM
ARE STATEWIDE PLAN AFTER. I DO
CLEAR TIMELINE CLIMATE AND NOW
IS THAT THE THAT CLIMATE FOR
NATIONAL LAN. YOU CAN TAKE YOUR
OTHER IMPORTANT. A PERSONAL
NOTE AFTER WORK IN THE STATE
NEARLY YEARS THIS ISSUE AND CAL.
I A LOT OF PRIDE. BEING
PROGRESS IN NOT AND IT BUILT
DIRECTLY OF THE KEY CHALLENGES.
THAT THE FOUNDER OF THE AT THE
THAT THE IN THE EARLY YEARS OF
FOR A- THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO
MUCH M. ONE HERE FOR MY G.
GREAT THANK YOU CHAIR MEMBERS
MAINTAINING MERYL I'M A POLICY
DIRECTOR FOR THE CALIFORNIA
CLIMATE IN AGRICULTURE NETWORK
WHERE A COALITION OF FORMER
LEADERS IN SUSTAINABLE
AGRICULTURE GROUPS WORKING TO
ADVANCE AGRICULTURAL SOLUTIONS
TO CLIMATE CHANGE. WE ARE VERY
PLEASED TO SUPPORT AB TWENTY
NINE FIFTY FOUR WHICH
RECOGNIZES THE NEED FOR
CALIFORNIA TO ADVANCE THE
CLINICAL AND RELATED STRATEGIES
FOR BASS TO END IMPORTANCE
NATURAL WORKING LANDS. I WANTED
IT ADDRESS SOME OF THE COULD
ABOUT THE BILL RAISED BY MY
COLLEAGUES IN AGRICULTURE. WE
HAVE MODELING FOR THE STATE AND
FROM OTHER RESEARCHERS THAT
QUANTIFIES THE POTENTIAL FOR
INCREASED CARBON SEQUESTRATION
FROM AGRICULTURE BASED ON
DIVERSITY IN HARLEM PRACTICES
AS WELL AS OTHER STRATEGIES.
AND I. SHOULD THE BILL BE
NECESSARILY THINK IT WILL BE
NECESSARY TO HAVE A VARIETY OF
PASSED FORWARD TO REDUCE
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS AND
INCREASED CARBON SINKS ON
FARMS. AB TWENTY NINE FIFTY
FOUR DOES NOTHING TO TAKE AWAY
THAT FLEXIBILITY AND DIVERSITY.
OF APPROACH MOREOVER MANY
PROGRAM ARE UP THE AIR IN THE
STATE- AS WE GRAPPLE WITH THE
FINANCIAL IMPACT OF THE CODE
NINETEEN CRISIS. WE WILL
NECESSARILY NEED TO TURN OUR
ATTENTION TO FUTURE FUNDING
SOURCES TO SUPPORT THE CLAIM
EFFORT. BUT REGARDLESS THE
SHORT TERM BUT BUDGET DEFICIT
AB TWENTY NINE FIFTY FOUR HAS A
LONGER TERM VIEW OF WHAT IS
NECESSARY TO HELP THE STATE
SHE'S AT TWENTY FORTY FIVE
CARBON NEUTRALITY GOAL. WE
SHOULD NOT BE STYMIED BY AIR
INDIA CRISIS. NO IN AB NINE
FIFTY FOUR WOULD REQUIRE THE
STATE TO IMPOSE REGULATIONS ON
AGRICULTURE TO LIMIT OR CHANGE
THE TYPE OF CROP. GROWN IN
CALIFORNIA. THE BILL SIMPLY
STATE THAT ERA BE INTENSIFIED
BY CLIMATE GOAL INCLUDES
NATURAL WORKING LANDS AND
INCLUDES NATIONAL WORKING LIVE
STRATEGIES IN THE BUILDING PLAN.
DURING THE GROUND MAKE WE HAD
MORE FORMER THAN EVER BEFORE
SIGNING UP FOR THE HEALTHY
SOILS PROGRAM WHICH IS JUST ONE
OF THE SWEET OF CLIMATE SMART
AGRICULTURE PROGRAMS AVAILABLE
IN THE STATE. ARTNET FOOD
AGRICULTURE RECEIVED A RECORD
NUMBER SIX HUNDRED HEALTHY
SOILS APPLICATIONS FROM FARMERS
AND RANCHERS. IN MARCH AND
APRIL. AB TWENTY NINE FIFTY
FOUR WILL ALLOW THE STATE TO
UNDERSTAND THE OPPORTUNITIES
THE SCALE OF THIS WORK IN
MEANINGFUL WAYS AND FARMERS ARE
DEMONSTRATING TODAY EVEN DURING
THESE UNCERTAIN TIMES THAT THEY
WANT THE STATE'S CLIMATE
EFFORTS CONTINUE. WE URGE YOUR
SUPPORT. OKAY THANK YOU THANK
YOU MISS MORROW. ALL RIGHT I
DON'T SEE ANYONE IN THE GALLERY
I DON'T SEE ONE IN IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE LET'S LET'S TURN THE
PHONE LINES. FOR FOLKS WHO WANT
TO EXPRESS THEIR SUPPORT FOR A
BETWEEN NINE FIFTY FOUR. SURE
IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY NINE FIFTY FOUR PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN IS THERE-
THAT ISN'T SUPPORT OF AB.
TWENTY NINE FIFTY FOUR ONE NINE
ZERO. ONCE AGAIN I DIDN'T
SUPPORT OF AB. TWENTY NINE
FIFTY FOUR ONE BEN IS THERE ON
YOUR PHONE. I DO NOT CREATE
QUEUED UP FOR THAT. OKAY ALL
RIGHT LET'S GO TO. OKAY HANG ON
ONE SECOND THERE MAY BE FOLKS-
THAT ON THE DIFFERENT QUEUES AT
RIGHT. WE'RE GONNA HANG ON ONE
SECOND IS THE CHECK AGAIN. AND.
WE HAVE IT FROM THE LINE AT ONE
OO EIGHT THAT MIGHT WANT TO
WAIT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
SACRAMENTO IN SUPPORT. OKAY LET.
ONE MOMENT FAIR THERE'S ANOTHER
FEW I'M HERE HOLD ON ONE MOMENT
OKAY THANK YOU. ONE TWENTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN ONE
TWENTY FIVE. GOOD AFTERNOON
JERRY MEMBERS CARLA HERE THEY
ON BEHALF OF THE FOLLOWING
ORGANISATIONS IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF AB TWENTY NINE FIFTY FOUR
OUT CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL
DEFENSE LINE CALIFORNIA REALLY
ANOTHER LAND TRUST NATIONAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL THE
TRUST FOR PUBLIC LAND DEFENDERS
OF WILDLIFE. PACIFIC FOR A
STRETCH HARBANS LEGAL INTO TWO
AMERICAN FARMLAND TRUST
CALIFORNIANS AGAINST WASTE AND
CLIMATE RESULT THANK YOU SO
MUCH. CONVECTIVE FROM LINE ONE
SEVENTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU MISTER
MARTIN STRYKER AGAIN ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF RESOURCE CONSERVATION
DISTRICT AND THE SANTA CLARA
VALLEY OPEN SPACE THIRTY IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU IN
THE NEXT ONE IS FROM TH LINE
OF ONE MINUTE. TWENTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS
NOW OPEN. MEMBERS MEYER ON
BEHALF OF THE- REGIONAL SPACE
JUST. THE CALIFORNIA HABITAT
CONSERVATION PLAN COALITION.
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
LOCAL CONSERVATION CORPS B. SAY
THAT RECKLESSLY AND COMMUNITY
NATURE CONNECTION AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THE NEXT
COMES FROM THE LINE OF ONE
THIRTY THREE YOU'RE LYING IF.
OKAY THAT MIGHT HAS DROPPED OUT.
AND WE HAVE ONE COMING FROM THE
LINE OF ONE THIRTY FIVE. OKAY
WE DO NOT HAVE ANY MORE IN Q.
OKAY THANK YOU SO MUCH. ALL
RIGHT LET'S- NOW GO TO THE
OPPOSITION SO WE'RE FIRST GOING
TO HEAR FROM TAYLOR RUSSIAN
NEWS POLICY ADVOCATE WITH THE
FARM BUREAU AND THEN LAST
SILVERTHORNE FROM THE CHAMBER
OF BOTH OF THEM BOTH TAYLOR AND
THEY ARE ON THE PHONE LINES.
LET'S START WITH YOU TAYLOR.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND HAVE
A MEMBER CAN RUSSIAN THE
CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU I WE
ALONG WITH COLLEGE THE
AGRICULTURE COMMUNITY WHO
REPRESENT FARMERS ARE OPPOSED.
NINE FIFTY FOUR WE DON'T
DISPUTE THAT OUR LAND MANY OF
RETURN PRODUCTION I. ONE OF THE
SOLUTION TO CLIMATE CHANGE I
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
DON'T. FIND ACTUALLY PROUD OF
THAT AND WE WANT EVERYTHING
THAT DISCUSSION BUT WE ALSO
KNOW IF WE'RE GOING TO BE
SUCCESSFUL WE NEED TO TAKE A
THOUGHTFUL APPROACH THAT
REALLY. MATTERS THE DIVERSITY
OF OUR CAPACITY AND ALL. THE
STATE FUNDING AND SO YOU KNOW
WE KNOW INHERENTLY OUR LAND
WHAT'S YOUR CARBON BUT IN ORDER
FOR US TO MORE. AT FARM. POCKET
AND- ON. AFTER RESULT IN MEDIA
THE MONSTER INCREASES IN YIELD
OR QUALITY. IMPROVE OR THAT AND
THAT. WHERE PEOPLE BALBOA PARK
HOW MADE THE- DECISION. AND
WE'RE PROBABLY. THE LOW HANGING
FRUIT BEEN. SO FAR CRY TO DO
EVEN MORE TO THEY ARE DOING AND
SHE'S GOAL AND- THEY REALLY
NEED FINANCE REPORT. AND STATE
PROVIDED FUNDS THIS WORK BUT
THEY DONE. IN AND- LOOKING AT
THE CAR DEFICIT AND- FOR THE
FOLLOW YEAR PARTICULARLY. RIGHT
WHICH TRADITIONALLY FUNDED WORK
BUT I THINK MORE IMPORTANTLY.
THE DOWNWARD TRAJECTORY ON OUR
ECONOMIC VIABILITY MAKES IT
UNLIKELY THAT FUNDING WILL
CONTINUE TO BE ADEQUATE TO MEET
ME. SO CONSIDER THAT WERE
REALLY DISAPPOINTED THE BILL
DOESN'T MAKE ANY MEANT. AT ALL
HAVE TO BE. FUNDING
ADDITIONALLY WORKING LEARNING
MAKING. TOWARD THE GOAL IT WILL.
PERHAPS INTENTIONALLY CREATE
WINNERS AND LOSERS- SOME
COMMODITIES YEAH ACTUALLY HAVE
GREATER CAPACITY. LESSER CARBON
THAN OTHERS EVEN IF I PLAN TO
MANAGE THE PROGRAM LATE. SO
GIVEN NOT SOME PUNK MAY HAVE A
COMPETITIVE ADVANTAGE IN
APPLYING FOR AND- OVER OTHERS.
IT'S FUNDING. ALL FOR
OPERATIONS. AT ARMS DON'T HAVE
ACCESS TO CASH. ON THE- OKAY
PROVIDE MATCH FUNDS. I READILY
AS FAR LARGER AMONG PROFITABLE.
AND SO WELL THERE CERTAINLY YOU
KNOW HI PROFIT MAJOR. DOING
GREAT WORK IN A HEARTBEAT
SITUATION THEY ARE MINOR. FARMS
ARE ON IMPORTANT. SO ADDED
COMPONENT IN BILL YOU INSURE
THAT THE H. OF THE WILL.
REGIONAL AND COMMODITY EQUITY.
WE FEARED THE INCOMING. WILL
FOR ENSURE. THAT SORT OF
DISPARITIES I THINK MY BROADLY
SHOULD THE- WE FARMERS MAKE IT
IS. ON WHAT TO PLANT BASED ON
WHAT DRAW DOWN THE CARBON.
VERSUS WHAT'S BEST FOR THEIR
OPERATION ORDER LANDS OR WHAT
THE MARKET HE- AND WE'RE GOING
TO MORE CONSOLIDATION OF FARMS
AND. OCTOBER EIGHTH. AND
ACTIVISTS FOR WHAT. A RIGHT
KIND OF. CONTINUE TO WRITE CAL.
L. CLOSE THE THING THAT DID
SHOULD BE THAN BECAUSE WHAT CAR
CAR YOU DOING IT SHOULD BE AN
OFFER BY THE LESS TO DIRECT
CARD MANAGE THE- THAT WE HAD
FARMERS NORCO TO A WHICH
FUNDING ACT. SO WE TO LEGISLATE
BACK TO THIS OPPORTUNITY GIVE
FARMERS THE TOOLS TO BE. AND
UNFORTUNATELY THE WAY TO NINE
FIFTY NINE FIFTY FOUR CRACKED
IT HURT BY FOR THAT AND THESE
REASONS WE I REQUEST YOU KNOW
BUT THANK YOU. OKAY THANK. ALL
RIGHT LET'S LET'S. WAIT A
MINUTE WE HAVE TO GO TO SO WHEN
YOU GO TO. RIGHT OKAY WE HAVE
DIFFERENTLY I YEP OKAY SO SORRY
BUT THAT'S ONLY A- THANK
SENATOR KERRY MEMBERS AS WE.
FURTHER FROM THE CAL CHAMBER.
WE ARE REGRET OPPOSE TO THE
BILL THE COMMUNITY IT WAS
ALREADY AND TO DISCUSS. THE
WIND RIGHT OF STAKEHOLDER. WHAT
NEED. OF CRIME AND YOU TRY WE
MEETING. AS THE COMMITTEE. AND
YOU KNOW THE AND- THIS WOULD BE
THE FIRST TIME THE CLIENT
NEUTRALITY BEING CODIFIED IN
STATE LAW AND SO THE WORD. AND
THE TURN THAT ARE USED IN THE
BILL ARE VERY IMPORTANT-
BECAUSE- OF. THOSE STAKEHOLDERS
HE DID NOT HAPPEN- THERE WERE
FOUR BILLS MOVING IN THIS IS
ONE THAT CONTINUES. I WANT TO
BE. TWO ISSUE THAT ARE A MORE
TEND FOR LEVEL. BECAUSE THE
ISSUES AND THEN WITHIN THE
DON'T APPLY TO THE NATIONAL
MORE ROUND THE FLIGHT. GENERAL
EIGHTY TWO YEAH THE BILL DE
LIMIT. BE DEAFENED AROUND NECK.
IN A WAY THAT APPLY NOT TO ALL.
WE ALL KNOW THAT CONTROL THE IN
CAR REDUCTION BIRTHDAY THEY'RE
ALL AND GET THAN OTHER. HE
HOOKED IT ALL KIND OF
NEUTRALITY PRICE COULD SHE ALL
THE BENEFITS ISSUES ANY SHOULD
BE YOU GO BETTER ISSUE THERE IN.
ACTUALLY IT NEED TO I THINK WE
SHOULD THAT ONE OF COURSE THE
WAY BILL IS RIGHT NOW WOULD
NEED TO GETTING ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT WOULD BE ABLE TO. AND ALL
IN THE DEFINITION AROUND CLASS
TO TRY THE LADY THE THAT HE IS
THAT ALL POLL HE CAN. UNDER
COULD ARE. ALL HAS CALL BUT
ALSO HAVE BIODIVERSITY THAT AND
MY K. WHILE WOULD BE WONDERFUL
IF THE BILL CARBON NEUTRALITY.
COULD BE CHEAP ALL THOSE HEALTH
BENEFITS IN SOME AREAS MAY NOT
SENSE AND I DON'T THINK WE WANT
TO GET THE ABILITY ARE
TECHNOLOGY THAT MAKES
INCREDIBLE STRIDES IN CARBON
EMISSION PRODUCTION BUT MAYBE
DOESN'T HAVE THAT AIR QUALITY
IN IN AREAS THAT DON'T NEED
THAT. BUT I THINK WE'RE WE'RE
BECAUSE THAT STAKEHOLDER
DISCUSSION AROUND WHAT WHAT THE
LEGISLATURE ONE CLIMATE
NEUTRALITY BE. AN OPEN MAJOR
ISSUES WITH THE BILL AND THEN
THE SECOND ISSUE MY COLLEAGUE
TAYLOR DID TOUCH UPON THEM AND
THE AUTHOR INDICATED THE BILL
DIRECTS A. R. T. THE FACT. THIS
IS THE D. A. R. B. ALL. DOING
THAT. I'M SORRY AIR B. CREE I
DRAFT NATIONAL WORKING WITH
PLAN IT RELEASED. IT IS MOVING
THERE HOW IS IT GREAT RECORD
THE GOVERNOR'S CAR SHALL. THE
GOAL FROM THE PLAN ITSELF THAT
IMPLEMENT OF THE PLANWILL
BEGIN IMMEDIATE. AND ON
OCCASION INCLUDE PROCTOR LEARN
THROUGHOUT THE PRIOR AS THE
POTENTIAL FOR NOW WORK THERE.
ARE QUITE A- INCLUDING CAR
NEUTRAL. FEATURE UPDATE THE
SKOKIE PLAN WE REPLY RIFAI.
KITTLE FOR NASH RATE RANCHO.
PUBLIC HEALTH. FINACLE IN EAGAN
BENEFITS. THE REALITY IS THAT
THIS IS IT NECESSARY TO THE
GOAL STOCK BY IT WOULD BE A
VERY WELL AT THIS BILL WOULD
AIR B. WOULD CONTAIN TO FOR
THIS ON THIS IS FOR CALL SO OUT
OF MEDIUM THOSE YOU THAT I
FORTUNATE MAYBE OF THE ISSUE SO
THE DEATH. OF THE CHANGE THAT
WOULD NOT IN ORDER MAKE SURE
NOT LIMITING TECHNOLOGY WE'RE
TO RUNNING OPTION REMEMBER
OPPOSITION. WE'LL GO TO THE
PHONE LINES- TO SEE IF ANYONE
IS IN QUEUE. TO VOICE
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL AB
TWENTY NINE FIFTY FOUR. WE DO
HAVE. PEOPLE IN QUEUE FOR AB
TWENTY NINE FIFTY FOUR PLEASE
CALL HEADLINE NUMBER ONE THE
THIRTY EIGHT. APOLOGIES I'M
ACTUALLY CALLING INTO COURT THE
CALIFORNIA COMPANY VOTE IN OF
AB TWENTY FOUR THANK YOU. OKAY.
AND WE HAVE A FRONT LINE A ONE
THIRTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NINE ONE THIRTY SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS NOW OPEN. AND WE WILL GO TO
THE LINE OF ONE THREE YOUR LINE
IS NOW OPEN. WITH THAT BEING ME
CAN YOU HEAR ME. AT ISSUE I HAD
OKAY GOOD THANK YOU RIGHT I WAS
TRYING TO CALL IN EARLIER I AM
ALL HASTINGS. IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY NINE FIFTY FOUR FOR THE
CLIMATE CENTER THANK YOU. THANK
YOU WE WILL TRY LINE ONE TO
THIRTY SEVEN AGAIN PLEASE LINE
ONE THIRTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
NOW OPEN. HEY WE ARE GOING IN
OPPOSITION OF THE AB TWENTY
NINE AT FIFTY FOUR. DECISION OF
ABIA TWENTY NINE FIFTY FOUR
THAT'S ONE ZERO. ONCE AGAIN
THAT IS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
AND
ONCE AGAIN OPPOSITION OF AB AT
TWENTY NINE FIFTY FOUR OR ONE
THAT THEN IS THE ROLE. AND WE
HAVE A LINE OF ONE THIRTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YOUR LINE IS
NOW OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON THAT
YOUR CARE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE LARA KNOWING HE GOT
MAP OF CALIFORNIA CONGENERS AND
BURDENS OF PEACE IN WESTERN
PRACTICES ASSOCIATION AMERICAN
DISPATCH HERE VERY MUCH RUN
HEALTH AT THAT THE ASIAN
CALIFORNIA FRESH FRUIT
ASSOCIATION INVOLVED OTHERS IN
OPPOSITION. FOR THE REASONS
STATED BY THE FARM BUREAU
CHAMBER THANK. YOU THANK YOU
AND NOW BE LAW ONE. SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE IS NOW
OPEN. SELL BEYOND IN BE UP TO
THE ALL MIDDLE CAL. CALIFORNIA
SEASON HE'S IN CALIFORNIA FEES
WE MUST OPPOSE THIS POINT. THE
OPPOSITION OF AB AT TWENTY NINE
AT FIFTY FOUR ONE THEN IF ZERO.
I DO NOT SHOW ANY WARNING Q. AS
OF RIGHT NOW OKAY. ALL RIGHT-
THANK YOU VERY MUCH EVERYBODY
FOR CALLING AND I SEE CENTER
SKINNER HAS A QUESTION WERE
WERE NOW- OPENED UP TO
COMMITTEE DISCUSSION CENTER
SKINNER. YES THANK YOU- CHAIR
AND I WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD I AM
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL I WILL
MOVE IT NOW. AND. I JUST- THERE
WE HAVE LEGITIMATELY BEEN VERY
FOCUSED ON THE PANDEMIC THAT WE
ARE EXPERIENCING AN ECONOMIC
DOWNTURN AS A RESULT OF THAT
AND TO MAKE. HOWEVER IT IS.
BIGGEST CHALLENGE TO OT ONLY
OUR STATE OUR COUNTRY INNER
GLOW BUT ALSO TO OUR GLOW IS
THE CLIMATE CRISIS AND IRATE
WHILE. THE VARIOUS THINGS THAT
WE DO TO ADDRESS IT. SHE ALWAYS
HAVE MULTIPLE SOCKS. IT IS
IMPERATIVE. ABSOLUTELY
IMPERATIVE WE HAVE LOST SO MUCH
GROUND AND WE'RE AT THE POINT
NOW WHERE THE ICE SHEETS IN
GREENLAND ARE PAST THE POINT OF
NO RETURN THEY WILL NOT EVEN IF
WE WERE TO STOP. ALL RELEASES
OF CARBON WE WILL NOT BE ABLE
TO RESTORE THE ICE ON GREENLAND
WE CANNOT GET TO THAT POINT. IN
EITHER OF OUR POLLS IN
ANTARCTICA OR THE NORTH POLE
YOU CAN NOT AFFORD TO GET TO
THAT POINT. AND WE ARE
DANGEROUSLY CLOSE TO THAT POINT
SO. WELL THIS BILL ALONE WILL
NOT REVERSE THIS IS INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT. AND I URGE. ALL OF
THE MEMBERS TO SUPPORT IT AND I
THINK THE MEMBER OR BRING IT
FORWARD AND AS I INDICATED
BEFORE I'M OF THE BILL. THEY
WERE CAST. RICHARD THANK YOU I
WILL NOT BE THE SUPPORTING THE
BILL IN THE FORM DEBTS THAT
IT'S IN I A- I APPRECIATE THE
ENCOURAGEMENT TO THE MEMBERS
HAVE I WILL. REMIND THE
ADVOCATES THAT THE SENATE
BUDGET COMMITTEE THE LAST TWO
YEARS HAS HAD FUNDING IN THE
BUDGET FOR FROM CAP AND TRADE
IN IN ORDER TO DIRECT IT AT. AT
WORKING LANDS THIS YEAR THERE
WAS A HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
THAT WAS REMOVED BY THE
GOVERNOR IN THE ASSEMBLY IN THE
FINAL NEGOTIATION SO THIS IS
NOT A NEW TOPIC. AND THE
SCALLOPS SENATE IS COMMITTED TO
WORKING ON WORKING LANDS WITH
THAT SAID MY CONCERN AND I'M
SURE THE MEN WILL SHARE THEM
WITH THE AUTHOR IS IT THIS
GREAT EXPERIENCE THE AUTHORITY
OF THE OF THE YEAR BOARD- AND
I'M- CONCERNED WITH THAT- THE
TWO THOUSAND SEVEN. SCHOOL PLAN
HAS A LOT OF. THE CRITICISM
THAT HAS BEEN. POLICE TO GRAB
GET IT YOU KNOW BY. CAN TED THE
AIRPORTS RIGHT NOW AND K. AND
TRADE HASN'T CORRECT THE
CHALLENGE THE- IN A FISH THAT
WE'VE WE'VE OUT TO IT SO THAT
THAT ARE IN THAT PROGRAM RUNS
BY CODIFY. THE NEW. TO I'M
NEUTRAL IT LET THE AIRPORT OFF
THE HOOK THAT THEY HAVE TO.
THAT IN A FEW IN AN ATTIC THAT
THEY HAVE WITH THE CURRENCY
PLAY IN THE CURRENT CAP AND
TRADE AND ALLOWS HIM TO USE
THAT. ARE IN TRUCK COVER
NEUTRAL IN THE FUTURE TO CHI
THE GOALS WE WANT ALL THE
COMPONENT PARTS WORKING SO
THAT. AT THAT CONCERNS ME I
DON'T BELIEVE THAT THE AIRPORT
SHOULD BE THE FINAL SAY ON CRAP
AND SHRUBLANDS NATURAL RESOURCE
THIS IS A MORE. AGENCY TO BE
ABLE TO WE SHOOT FOR A IN THE
GRASS. ALSO IS WE. AS A MEMBER
MULLINS BURKE POINTS OUT OFFICE
OF. SEARCH IS THE- INTER AGENCY
PLAN A SALUTE ASSOCI OBVIOUSLY
THE BOARD SHOULD HAVE SOMETHING
TO DO ON THAT WORK LAND. BUT WE
DO IT SO. RELATED IT'S A LEAD
TO IT'S. THREE IT'S ONE OF THE
CHALLENGES THAT THAT. I AM. HI
I HAVE ADDITIONALLY. P. THE
BILL. FORMALIZES THE NATURAL
AND WORKING LANDS AS PART OF
THE SCOPING PROCESS IN AGAIN
THIS THESE SECTORS ARE NOT
INCLUDED IN THE GREENHOUSE GAS
INVENTORIES THAT WERE YOU'RE
USED TO MEASURE COMPLIANCE WITH
SB THIRTY TWO OR AB THIRTY TWO
AND THEREFORE ARE RELEVANT FOR
THAT SCHOOL BEING PLANNED OR
RELEVANT FOR THE- OUR GOALS THE
BESIDES A CAP AND TRADE X.
AMENDMENT SHOULD BE REQUIRED
THAT CARVE DEVELOP. INTO EIGHT.
THROUGH RULE MAKING AS THAT ARE
TO THEM OFFICIALLY PART OF THE
STATE GREEN GAS INVENTORY
INCLUDING A FULL BETTER PUTTING
WORKING LANDS. IN THE IN PART
AS A SCOPING PLAN- WHICH- THEY
HAVEN'T DONE THIS STATE AND
THEY COULDN'T DO THIS UNLESS
THEY CHANGED THAT RULE MAKING
ANALYSIS AMENDMENT WOULD ALSO
BE NEEDED. THAT ANY DECISION TO
USE NATURAL WORKING LANDS IN
THE SCOPING PLAN WILL ACCOUNT
FOR BOTH SEQUESTRATION AND
EMISSIONS SO RIGHT NOW WE HAVE
A FIRE WE DON'T COUNT THOSE
ADMISSIONS IN OUR GREENHOUSE
GAS. SO IF YOU GET A CAN'T SEEK
AND IT'S ONLY THAT YOU CAN'T
EMISSIONS AND AMENDMENTS SHOULD
ALSO BE. INCLUDED ON SOIL
CARBON PRACTICE IT'S TO IF
YOU'RE INCLUDING SOIL
PRACTICING THE SEQUESTRATION
YOU NEED TO BE AT LEAST A METER
IN DEPTH BECAUSE SHALLOW
CREDITING HAS SHOWN TO BE AN
EFFECTIVELY. INEFFECTIVE IN
DELIVERING THE CLIMATE BENEFITS
A WEEK YOU KNOW IT'S LIKE-
OFFSETS THAT WE HAVE A CARBON
PROGRAM WE FIND THAT THEY WOULD
HAVE BEEN DELIGHTED ON THIS
ACTIVITY WITHOUT THE- CITY
AIRPORT GIVE SOME CREDIT. AND
I'M CONCERNED IF WE DON'T DO
PROPER SEQUESTRATION WORKING
LANDS DON'T GET IT AND IN SOME
OF THE FINDINGS- IN THE BILL I
WOULD. WANT THEM TO BE STRICKEN
I'M SHARING THAT WITH THE
ADVOCATES FOR THE DAY HERE
CRITICISM I WOULD BE GOING. UP
BILL. YOUR BY CONCERNED THE
STAFF. IN WITH THE AUTHOR THANK
YOU. THANK YOU I MEAN IS IT I
SEE IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING YOU
BEEN DISCUSS SOME OF THESE WITH
AUTHOR THE AUTHOR IS OPEN AT
LEAST THAT MUCH OF THE
CONVERSATION THAT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING. YEAH SO WE HAD-
INITIAL- THE CONVERSATION YOU
KNOW OBVIOUSLY WITH THE
COMPRESSED- THE TIMELINE THAT
WERE WORKING UNDER- YEAH WE
HAVE HAD THAT INITIAL- I
CONVERSATION AND LOOK FORWARD
TO ENGAGING FOR THE- OKAY I
WOULD I WOULD CERTAINLY
ENCOURAGE. HI TRACY CENTER
HEALTH CENTRE DOLLY CENTER
STERN CENTER BATES WITH MICHAEL
GETS RICHER JUST VERY BRIEFLY-
YOU KNOW I DO SUPPORT THE-COMMENTS OF US SENATOR SKINNER
I THINK SHE WAS OF RIGHT ON THE
MARK WITH WHICH SHE HAD TO SAY.
RELATED TO THE TO THE BILL- I.
DISAGREE WITH SENATOR WHITE
CASKET SOMEONE WHO SAT ON THE
AIR RESOURCES BOARD IN TWO
THOUSAND AND SEVEN. IS HE A
REAL FIRST AFTER THE FIRST
ITERATION OF THE- SCOPING PLAN
WAS DEVELOPED THIS IS THE
PLACE. THAT IS THE PLACE TO
DISCUSS THIS TO DEAL WITH IT
AND TO- LOOK AT THE-
SEQUESTRATION AND ALL OF THE
OTHER ISSUES INVOLVED I JUST
THINK THE- AIR RESOURCES BOARD
IS THE APPROPRIATE PLACE. TO
HAVE THIS DISEASE THE PURPOSE
I'M SORRY. YOU SAID YOU GET IS
THE EVERYBODY'S. YES YES OKAY
OKAY YEAH ABSOLUTELY SO. I'LL
CERTAINLY BE WHICH IS
SUPPORTING THE BILL TODAY.
THANK YOU SENATE HEALTH CENTER
DOLLARS. FAVORITES SHARE.
BECAUSE I DON'T KNOW WHERE TO
START. THAT'S A AS SOMEBODY WHO
IS FAMILIES FOR GENERATIONS
BEEN WORKING LANDSCAPE. AND
I'VE ALSO BEEN REGULATED BY.
MULTIPLE AGENCIES ABOUT HOW I
OPERATE MY WORKING LANDSCAPE SO
FIRST I WANTED TO SAY TO THE
AUTHOR I TOTALLY RESPECTED AND
UNDERSTAND- YEAH THERE'S A
CHALLENGE AND I LOOK AT THE
LOOK AT THE SUPPORT AND I LOOK
AT THE OPPOSITION. OPPOSITIONS
ARE MY NEIGHBORS WHO ARE
PUTTING FOOD ON THE TABLE FOR.
CALIFORNIANS AND THE LIKE IN
THE IN THE IN THE PEOPLE WHO
SUPPORT IT ARE PEOPLE THAT
RECEIVED THE GRANT MONIES THAT.
DO CONSERVATION WORK ON AROUND
IN AND NEAR ME SO I GET THAT I
GET THAT THEY'RE WANTING MORE
MONEY AND- AND TO DRIVE N. IN
IT TO THE POINT THAT. THAT THE
GRACE DINNER FROM BERKELEY
SENATOR SKINNER MADE ABOUT YOU
KNOW. COBIT IN AND THEIR LIKES
WE REALLY HAVEN'T HAD A ROBUST
DEBATE THIS BILL. NEED TO
DEBATE THERE'S A LOT OF MOVING
PIECES IN THIS PIECE OF
LEGISLATION THERE'S- NATURAL
RESOURCES THERE'S FIRE THERE'S
A LOT OF THINGS THAT WE'VE
TALKED ABOUT. OVER THE PAST
EIGHT YEARS I'VE BEEN IN TRYING
TO. TALK ABOUT SEQUESTERING
CARBON AND HOW WE CAN ON IT AND
HOW WE WHAT WHAT WHAT EMISSIONS
ARE WHEN YOU. WHEN YOU HAVE A
FIRE OR YOU HAVE A METAL YOUR
THAT YOU'RE TRYING TO PUT BACK
IN I MEAN I'VE DONE AND- I
WASN'T THESE BUT ON THIS YEAR
AMERICAN. THESE WORKING LANDS.
WE ON AND I THINK THAT WE'RE
DOING A DISSERVICE TO THE
PEOPLE WHO OWN LAND AND THE
PEOPLE WHO ARE TRYING TO MAKE
THAT BALANCE THAT WE HAVE ARE
WE MOVING THIS BILL FORWARD AYE
AYE. I DON'T SEE HOW THIS FITS
IN THE COVE IT AT ALL I THINK
THIS NEEDS A LOT MORE DEBATE. A
LOT MORE TO DEBATE FROM.
PARTIES AT THE TABLE AND I'M
SAYING IS THE WAY THERE'S A LOT
OF ROOM TO GROW HERE I THINK WE
I THINK WE NEED. ABOUT HOW HE
MANAGED WELLS. BUT WHO DOES
THAT IS TO ME IN MY MIND IS NOT
THE AIRPORT. THERE NEEDS TO BE
THE DEPARTMENT OF FOOD NAG THE
TABLE THERE NEEDS TO BE FARM
THREE PEOPLE ALL TABLE BUT JUST
A- PUSHING DOWN ON I'VE BEEN.
ON THE END OF RISK. A LOT OF
WHAT I WOULD SAY BAD POLICIES I
PUSH BACK FOR YEARS. HONOR
FORESTRY PRACTICES. ON HOW WE
DO CARBON SEQUESTRATION THE
FORCED. YOU KNOW THERE'S A LOT
OF CALCULATIONS HERE THE NEED
TO TAKE PLACE. ABOUT THE AMOUNT
OF CARBON OR THE- MEAN. THERE'S
OVER 50% OF THE ROOT BASE OF A
TREE IS IN THE GROUND WHICH IS
THE QUESTION CAR ONCE GROWING
BUT WE WANT TO HARVEST THAT TOP
OR IT'S GOING TO BE OMITTED
OTHERWISE THERE'S A LOT TO BE
TALKED ABOUT IN THIS POSITION
THOSE REASONS. I THINK WE
SHOULD. WE'LL DO IT RIGHT
THERE'S NO URGENCY TO MOVE THIS
BILL. FORWARD AND DO IT WRONG
AND WE'RE GOING TO GIVE THE
POWER TO THE WRONG AGENCY MY
MIND AND I SEE THE PEOPLE WHO
ARE THE STAKEHOLDERS. THE
GENERATIONS OF THE FAMILY
MEMBERS LIKE MYSELF. ARE IN
OPPOSITION THIS BECAUSE WE NEED
TO TAKE OUR TIME AND DO IT
RIGHT SO FOR THOSE IS I NOT
GONNA BE BORING THE BILL TODAY.
AND I WOULD HOPE THAT THIS
REALLY DOESN'T MEET THE
STANDARD OF COVERT I GOT I GOT
BILL THE BARCODE WE'RE NOT IN A
VERY FRUSTRATED ABOUT THE FACT
THAT. REAL THEIR- PUTTING
NURSES. IN HOSPITAL. HERE IN
THOSE BILLS AND WE'RE HERE TO
BUILD A NEED TO TAKE MORE TIME
AND IT'S REALLY NOT DIRECTLY
RELATED TO COPE WITH SO I'M
FRUSTRATED THE FACT THAT. AND
SO I AND I KNOW. THAT I JUST
WANT TO BE RESPECTFUL TO
EVERYBODY HERE THAT IT DOES
IT'S NOT PERSONAL IT'S JUST
IT'S A VERY. FRUSTRATING IN A
SESSION HERE WHERE I SEE BILLS
LIKE THIS THAT NEED MORE WORK
AND I SEE BILLS THAT HAVE- AT.
COVERT RELATED THAT THERE BE
INTEREST SO FOR THOSE. THESE
OPPOSING THE BILL. PLEASE YEAH
OF COURSE YOU KNOW KNOW THIS
CERTAIN IS NOT. HERE AND BILL
AB BUT I BUT I GET YOUR I GET
YOUR BROADER POINT. I STERN.
THANK YOU MISS CHAIR GOOD COULD
DISCUSS SO FAR. WELL I GUESS
WHAT THE COMMENT IN A QUESTION
I WHAT I SENSE IS. FROM SOME OF
MY COLLEAGUES ARE THESE ONE OF
MY COLLEAGUE THAT THIS ISN'T
STRONG ENOUGH THAT THERE'S A
CONCERN THAT. PUTTING OUR
NATURAL WORKING LANDS IN A
CARBON NEUTRALITY CONTEXT
WOULDN'T BE TOUGH ENOUGH ON-
THOSE SECTORS. BUT ON THE OTHER
HAND I HEAR THAT THE BILL- IT
DOESN'T DO ANYTHING JUST LET
THE ADMINISTRATION KEEP DOING
THEIR THING THAT'S WHAT WE
HEARD FROM SOME OF THE
OPPOSITION. AND THEN CONCERNS
FROM SOME OF SOME OTHERS THAT
ARE OPPOSED SAYING OF THE BILL
THERE'S WAY TOO MUCH. SO RIGHT
I JUST WANT TO GET IT CLEAR
THIS LEGISLATION DOESN'T PUT
SOUL REGULATORY. OR EVEN ANY
PRIMARY REGULATORY AUTHORITY
WITH THE AIR RESOURCES BOARD
FOR ANY KIND OF ENFORCEMENT
REGIME OR ANY KIND OF
REGULATORY ACTION OR EVEN ANY
KIND OF PROJECT DEVELOPMENT TO
KIND OF WORK FOR INSTANCE GOING
ON AT. CDFA RIGHT NOW THROUGH A
VARIETY OF PROGRAMS THEY HAVE
THEIR- THROUGH DEPARTMENT OF
WATER RESOURCES WHERE FOLKS ARE
STRUGGLING TO MEET THE
SUSTAINABLE GROUNDWATER
MANAGEMENT ACT AND- WE NEED TO
W. ARE ENGAGED. ASEAN ARE A
NATURAL RESOURCE AGENCY WHERE
WE KNOW WE'VE ACTUALLY GOT A
BRING FORESTRY INTO THE URBAN
CONVERSATION. AND IN FACT
THAT'S THE ONLY WAY. TO HAVE A
SURVIVING TIMBER INDUSTRY IN
CALIFORNIA FRANKLY IS THROUGH
CARMEN AND I THINK FRANKLY THE
ONLY WAY FOR THE CALIFORNIA
FARMER. TO BE ABLE TO COMPETE
IN THE FUTURE OF AGRICULTURE IS
BY EMBRACING THIS REGION I HAVE
TO SAY THAT. I'M REALLY
DISAPPOINTED TO HEAR SO MANY
ADVOCATES I DON'T KNOW IF IT'S
FARMERSOR JUST THE ADVOCATES
AND- AND WORKING ABOUT- YOU
KNOW HOW. BUT I TALKED TO AND
THAT YOU KNOW I REPRESENT HERE.
INCREDIBLY CREATIVE AND
ENTREPRENEURIAL SPIRIT- FOLKS
INTERESTED IN BIO CHAR PEOPLE
LIKE AGRA MEN AND WATCHING AT
LEMAN ERA DOES THEIR CITRUS
BUSINESS AND IN VENTURA COUNTY
OR SOME OF THE RANCHERS WE WORK
WITHIN NORTH L. A. COUNTY
LOOKING AT RANGELANDS AND
GRAZING POTENTIAL. THIS TO ME
IS ACTUALLY THE FUTURE OF
PROSPERITY IN CALIFORNIA
AGRICULTURE SO I REALLY AM
DISAPPOINTED I WILL SAY IN THE
ANXIETY FROM THE OPPOSITION
TODAY LOOK I GET IT. BUT TO
CALL THIS AN OPEN ENDED- GIVE
AWAY TO THE YEAR RESOURCES
BORDER SOMEHOW- I DIDN'T HAVE
TO PUT IT- ON. A MARK AGAINST
CALIFORNIA AGRICULTURE I THINK
IT'S COMPLETELY
MISUNDERSTANDING THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS GO AND IN MY- MIND TO
IT IN. A VOTER TODAY IF THERE'S
NOT IN I'D LOVE TO BE ADDED ON
AS A CO AUTHOR TO THIS MEASURE
BECAUSE I DON'T THINK DEARBORN
SHOULD BE PURSUING THEIR
NATURAL WORKING LANDS POLICY.
WITH A LEGISLATURE. WE DON'T.
THE OPPOSITION JUST SAID THERE
WERE WILL KEEP YOU THEIR WORK
THERE'S ARE MRRY WERE GROUP
BIG. WILL WEIGH IN IN THE SCOPE
PLAN ON THIS WITHOUT. BUT I
THINK THE LEADS SHOULD BE. AS
CONTROL THIS FR IF WE WANT TO
GET A MORE FOR. ALONG THE LINES
THAT CENTER Y. CASKEY MENTIONED
WE'RE WE'RE REALLY CLEAR FOR
INSTANCE ABOUT HOW THE OPR
CITED THINGS FIT ST SOME OF
THEIR MODELING OR REALLY CLEAR
THAT YOU KNOW WANT. TO RISK
STAGE IN STATE TAKING THE
LABORING COME. FOR PLANS SEE.
ON AGRICULTURAL. LET'S LET'S
ADD A LITTLE BIT OF THAT. HERE
BUT I DON'T THINK THERE'S SOME
FUNDAMENTAL FLAW IN FACT I
THINK IF WE DON'T. GET THIS
BILL THROUGH THIS YEAR. IT WAS
THAT HAVE BEEN NEWBORNS A CAP
INTO THE SECTOR. THAT MONEY
THAT DIDN'T UP THIS YEAR THAT
HUNDRED MILLION IF WE HAD THIS
SPACE. EVERYONE AT THE- PUTTING
THEIR- FOR AND REAL HAVING SOME
MATH TO LEAN ON TO JUSTIFY IT.
I THINK THIS COULD BE THE
LARGEST FUTURE INVESTMENT IN
CALIFORNIA WHEN IT COMES TO
CLIMATE CHANGE MITIGATION. AND
SEQUESTRATION YOU CAN DO BOTH
AT THE SAME TIME SO I'LL BE
HARDLY SUPPORTING THIS BILL
TODAY. COULD YOU CENTER LET'S
GO NEXT TO CENTER BATES. I
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN NOT ALLEN UP
I GUESS MY CONCERNS WITH US ALL
ALONG THE LINE YOUR CENTER CHOI
CALCIUM SENATOR DOLLY BY THE
WAY I READ THIS IT SAYS IT
REQUIRES THE AIR RESOURCES
BOARD CREATE CLIMATE GOALS. FOR
NATURAL WORKING LANDS AND THOSE
SALINAS 90% OF WHAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT HERE IN THE NOT
SO HUGE OUR RESPONSIBILITY AND
ALSO AN AUTHORITY THAT I DON'T
FIND ANY WITHIN THE BILL.
REQUIRES IT BEING BROUGHT BACK
TO A LEGISLATURE IN. FACT IT MY
TIME ON. L. COMMITTEE ASKING
THIS ALLOWS FIVE OF APPS SERVED
ON IT I'VE ALWAYS REYES AYE
ISSUE THAT MUCH OF THE
RECOMMENDED MUCH OF THE-
REGULATIONS THAT ARE FOR MEDIAN
FORMATTED BY A R. B. REALLY
JUST STAY THERE EXIST THERE IN
AND BECOME MANDATES ON THOSE
WHO HAVE TO A LITTLE BEFORE THE
BOARD AND GET THEIR PROGRAM-
ARE THERE THIS PARTICULAR
ISSUE. IS SO FAR REACHING THEIR
SHOULD RECOMMENDATIONS THAT
COME BACK TO THIS LEGISLATURE
AND BACK TO WHAT SENATOR DALIAN
AND SENATOR Y. KASKI SAID THERE
NEEDS TO BE SOME DISCUSSION
ABOUT IT THERE NEEDS TO BE ON
THE STAKEHOLDER GROUP INVOLVED
BECAUSE IT IS A MUCH BIGGER IN
MUCH BROADER. THE NEW. SO THAT
REASON I WILL SUPPORT IT TODAY
AND I WILL HOPE. BECAUSE I WON
TO FACE YOU TO THE AUTHOR I
MEAN. CLIMATE WOLF WILL CLIMATE
CHANGE ALL OF THAT EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT I DON'T THINK ANYBODY
NOT MANY THERE ARE SOME. BAD TO
ADULTS DON'T UNDERSTAND THAT WE
HAVE GOT TO BE ARE YOU KNOW
WORKING VERY ARE. BIGGER US
LADY AND VERY COMMITTED TO
FINDING ANSWERS TO OUR DESK AND
HERE'S AN OPPORTUNITY AND THE
AUTHORS PROVIDED THAT BUT NOT I
DON'T THINK I PROCESS. THAT CAN
BE BALANCED AND FAIR WYNETTE
THERE ARE RECOMMENDATIONS THAT
THIS LEGISLATURE HAS A
RESPONSIBILITY. FOR INTO IN THE
FINAL IMPLEMENTATION THAT MAY
COME OUT AS MANDATE. SO I WON'T
SUPPORT IT TODAY BUT I DO
ENCOURAGE US TO CONTINUE TO
WORK. ON SOMETHING LIKE THIS
BUT MORE VOICES AND IT HAPPENS
OFTEN IN WHAT STATE. THERE
REALLY ARE ABLE TO PARTICIPATE
GRAHAM WELL WHAT CAN BE FAR
REACHING. I IMPACTS. THE BULLS
WILL BE. HE'S NOT NECESSARY
NEGATIVE IMPACTS. I ALSO THINK
YOU FOR OUR FOR. SPEAK ON.
HOPEFULLY GOING FORWARD YOU
IT'LL MUCH. WITH THE YOU MADAM
VICE CHAIR CLEARLY SOME MORE
WORK TO BE CENTER OF DOLLY.
THANK YOU I JUST WANT TO
RESPOND TO- SOME OF THE
COMMENTS THAT WERE MADE ABOUT.
THE ABSOLUTELY THERE'S A LOT OF
US FARMERS WHO ARE INVESTING IN
BIO CHAR AND SEQUESTERING
CARBON BUT I WANT BUT I WANT TO
SHARE THIS IS WAS WHEN WE HAD
AN OVERSIGHT HEARING IN THE
NATURAL RESOURCES OF. BACK WHEN
I WAS VICE CHAIR IN THE
ASSEMBLY. CHESBRO WITH THE
CHAIR. YOU KNOW WE HAD THE AIR
RESOURCES BOARD IN MERRY
NICHOLS RIGHT THERE AND WE ASK
ABOUT WHILE PARTISAN GIVING
ANALOGY HERE OF. OF I THINK THE
DISCONNECT. TO WIN WE GIVE THEM
CARTE BLANCHE TO GO. IN AND
THEY GO WE I WE SAID WHAT ABOUT
THE MISSIONS OF WILDFIRE.
VERSES YOU KNOW REGULATING.
COMBUSTIBLE ENGINES AND IT IS
LIKE THERE'S A TO JOB SO THE
MONEY SHOULD BE GOING TO. YOU
KNOW PERTAINING TO FORCED AND
THE LIKES AND YOU'RE SHUTTING
DOWN POWER PLANTS THAT TAKE
THAT FUEL TO TIME SHE SAID WELL
SOME PEOPLE HAVE TO GO OUT OF
BUSINESS. THAT'S THAT'S THE
WRONG ATTITUDE DATA NEED TO BE
WORK WITH THE LANDOWNER WORK
WITH TO WORK WITH THE PEOPLE
THAT ARE OUT THERE TRYING TO DO
THESE THINGS WITHOUT THE HAMMER
AND I THINK THIS IS THIS. IS IT
WHEN I HEARD THAT THE
GOVERNOR'S GOING ALONG IS DOING
HIS OWN THING. WELL THIS PUTS
IN LAWS TOGETHER THAT THE- REIN
HIM IN. IF WE DON'T LIKE IT
THIS ISN'T THIS ISN'T GONNA DO
IT. THIS IS GIVING THE POWER TO
THEIR BOARD WITHOUT THE
RESOURCES EVEN GET IT DONE IN
THE FIRST PLACE. WHICH IS WHAT.
CENTER Y. CASKEY BROUGHT UP SO
I WANTED TO JUST KIND OF PUSH
BACK A LITTLE BIT. THAT WE HAD
WE HAVEN'T ASKED THE NEXT
SESSION TO TAKE. IN A MORE
MEETING FOR WAY. BUT RIGHT. YOU
MISTER FOR INDULGE ME. PLEASE
ENTER- CENTER STARTED YOU HAVE
A THERE'S A FOLLOW UP FOR. NOW
HE WANTED HE WOULD HOST A
COLLEGE DEBATE ON THAT CARBONS
THE QUESTION WELL SORT OF IT'S-
A GREAT. FINALLY CANTOR DEBATER.
FURTHER THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER HE
LIVES IN THE HEART OF A ONE OF
THE MOST PRODUCTIVE
AGRICULTURAL REGIONS IN THE
STATE I THINK HE'S GOT A DEEP
DEEP PERSONAL EQUITY STAKE IN
ALL THESE OUTCOMES AND I
RESPECT THAT THERE CAN BE
DIFFERENCES OF OPINION I JUST
THINK WE CAN'T. FEAR CARBON
HERE I THINK IT'S ACTUALLY THE
FUTURE OF FARMING AND- I GET
THAT THERE'S A HISTORY OF.
MISTRUST AND YOU GOTTO HAVE
SOME EXPERT DO THIS WORK FOR
THE TARGET SETTING. THAT IS THE
AIRPORT'S LANE FOR THE REST OF
EVERYTHING I THINK WE GET CLEAR
ABOUT LET'S PUT CDS FANTOMEX
LET'S LET'S CROSS REFERENCE THE
NRA LET'S ASK LET'S SAY THERE
NEEDS TO BE ADEQUATE ONGOING
FUNDING TO MAKE THIS STUFF
WORKS. THERE'S SOME THERE'S
SOME WAYS THROUGH THIS I THINK
I DON'T THINK PEOPLE ACTUALLY
THAT FAR APART I GET THE TIME
IS TRICKY BUT- ACTUALLY I THINK
THOSE THAT ARE PART. THANK YOU
VERY CENTER OKAY- SEE NO
FURTHER COMMENT WELL AS I
CENTER SKINNER SINISTER. I
THANK YOU CHAIR SO I DIDN'T
RULE I ADDRESSED CLIMATE CRISIS
IN GENERAL WHEN I SPOKE I DID
NOT A DEPRESSED SO MUCH
SPECIFICALLY. THIS BILL BUT I
THINK GIVEN THE CONCERNS THAT
WERE RAISED. FIRST HEALTHY
SOILS ACT LANDS HAVE BE BEST
OPPORTUNITY RIGHT NOW GIVEN
WHAT CALIFORNIA HAS DONE TO
REDUCE EMISSIONS FROM FOSSIL
FUELS WHICH WOULD SIGNIFICANTLY
WE HAVE MADE SIGNIFICANT
PROGRESS. BUT WHAT WE HAVEN'T
DONE IS THIS INCREDIBLE
POTENTIAL FOR CARBON
SEQUESTRATION IN HEALTHY SOILS
IN THE SCIENCE ON IT IS
PHENOMENAL AND IT BENEFITS
ERICA COULTER. SO I APPRECIATE
YOU KNOW MY GOOD COLLEAGUE-
FROM THE NORTHERN EASTERN PART
OF OUR STATE CONCERN THAT. YOU
KNOW OUR RESOURCES BOARD MAY
NOT FACTOR THE NEEDS OF FARMERS
AS ADEQUATELY AS HE HOPES BUT I
GUESS WHAT WHAT I FEWEST NUMBER
ONE. THERE'S INCREDIBLE
POTENTIAL FOR CARBON
SEQUESTRATION AND HEALTHY SOILS
IT BENEFITS ACT AND NUMBER TWO.
RESOURCES BOARD THE LEGISLATURE
HAS GIVEN THEM THE
RESPONSIBILITY TO SET TARGETS
AND USED TO FROM THE DAY WE
FIRST TOOK A CLEAR POSITION OF
CLIMATE CRISIS AB THIRTY CHIU
AND ALL SUBSEQUENT LEGISLATION
NOW CERTAINLY THERE ARE MANY
OTHER AGENCIES THAT NEED TO BE
INVOLVED. AND WHAT I WOULD SAY
IN. THE BY TAKING THIS STEP NOW
WE HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY NEXT
YEAR. IN THE BUDGET OR ANY
SUBSEQUENT BILL TO ADD TO THIS
PROCESS WE OR TO EVEN REFINE.
THE AUTHORITY. THIS IS NOT AN
END ALL BE ALL AND IT DOES NOT
CUT OFF THE LEGISLATURE'S
ABILITY TO FURTHER SHAPE. BUT
IT IS A CLEAR MESSAGE NOW IN
THE APPROPRIATE MESSAGE NOW AND
I AM. APPRECIATE HAVING THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPECIFY MY
COMMENTS MORE TO THIS
PARTICULAR BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. THIRTY CENTER. OKAY
FIVE LET'S GIVE THE AUTHOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO CLOSE. YEAH I
DON'T REALLY YOU TAKE IN A
MOMENT IF YOU RESPONDED SENATOR
BAKER NO I REALLY APPRECIATE
ALL OF THE DEBATE TO THE ROBUST
DEBATE AND THE COMMENTS AND I
THINK. YOU KNOW A COMMENT THAT
WAS MADE BY SENATOR STERN- WAS
A VERY IMPORTANT A POINT THAT
HE MADE AND THAT THIS THIS THIS
THIS BILL- IS IT ABOUT THE AIR
RESOURCES THE OF THE A. R. B.
MANAGING SOILS AND- YOU KNOW.
IT CETERA. THIS LEGISLATION
ABOUT EXPLORING CREATING-
POSSIBLE OPTIONS. AND IF THOSE
OPTIONS ARE VIABLE. THEN THEY
ABSOLUTELY NEED TO COME BACK TO
THE LEGISLATURE FOR POSSIBLE
ADOPTION AND WE HAVE THAT
ROBUST DEBATE. ON HOW THOSE
OPTIONS COULD BE IMPLEMENTED
MOVING FORWARD. YOU KNOW I
APPRECIATE ALL OF THE COMMENTS
FROM OPPOSITION THE FARM BUREAU
YEAH I AGREE WITH THE FARM BILL
RECOGNIZE THE NEED TO CONSIDER
THE DIVERSE NATURE OF OUR
NATURAL WORK IN LANSING
CALIFORNIA UNLIKE ANY OTHER
STATE IT'S INCREDIBLY DIVERSE
AND THE VERY DIFFERENT AND HOW
WE- TREAT OUR NATURAL WORKING
LANDS- IN ONE PART OF STAYS IN
THE MUCH DIFFERENT OTHER PARTS
OF STATE AND THAT'S WHY THIS
BILL- YOU KNOW THIS THIS. THIS
THIS EFFORT IS A YOU KNOW IT
PROPOSES TO BE A COLLABORATIVE
EFFORT YOU KNOW THE BILL STATES
YOU KNOW FOR. FOR STATE
AGENCIES TO ENGAGE THE SUPPORT
PARTICIPATION IN PARTNERSHIP OF
THE BUSINESS COMMUNITY OF OUR
AGRICULTURAL SECTOR- YOU KNOW
IN IN IN YOU KNOW OTHER
COMMENTS THAT WERE MADE YOU
KNOW THAT THIS BILL IS. YOU
KNOW IT'S ABOUT CREATING A GOAL
AROUND NOW TO WORKING LANDS
CREATING A BLUEPRINT OR ROADMAP
IN THE END OF THIS. TO FUND
CARBON REMOVAL PRACTICE. AS THE
BILL STILL. THIS LEGISLATION.
SEEKS TO AGAIN ESTABLISH IT IS
BROUGH PLANT OF ESTABLISH A
BLUEPRINT- THIS DEVILISH IN
YOUR IDENTIFY PRACTICES BEST
PRACTICES POLICY INCENTIVES
POTENTIAL POLICY INCENTIVES.
AND POTENTIAL REDUCTIONS IN
BARRIERS THAT WOULD HELP
ACHIEVE THIS GOAL LONG TERM. IT
IF THERE IS A VIABLE OPTIONS
OUT THERE. IN THE NEED TO HAVE
THE CONSIDERATION OF THE FARM%
BILL SUGGESTING TO FUND THE
OPTIONS. BECAUSE CERTAINLY WHAT
IS BETTER YOU KNOW WHAT IS BEST
MANAGING OUR LANDS IS GOING TO
BE BEST FOR OUR STATE BEST FOR
OUR ENVIRONMENT IT'S GOING TO
HELP EXPAND OUR PRIME A
PORTFOLIO AND MEET OUR CLIMATE.
GOALS THAT WE HAVE AT THE STATE.
BUT WITH THAT MISTER CHAIR
REALLY APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY AGAIN TO BE HERE
APPRECIATE ALL OF THE COMMENTS.
YOU KNOW IN A I CAN'T EMPHASIZE
ENOUGH THE VALUE AND OF NATURAL
WORKING AS IN OUR STATE. THE
VALUE. OF TO OUR ENVIRONMENT TO
OUR ECONOMY AND THE VALUE TO
OUR COMMUNITIES. THE OVERSTATED
AND THIS BILL IS AN IMPORTANT
STEP. IN REALIZING THAT THAT
THAT HEARTLANDS- THAT YOU KNOW
NATIONAL WORKING LANDS IN THE
PIT IT DID IT DID YOU KNOW THAT
POTENTIAL. FOR HELPING US MEET
OUR GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSION
TARGETS. YOU KNOW AGAIN- THE
SCOPING PLAN THIS IS. YOU KNOW
IN IN IN I UNDERSTAND THE
COVERT NATURE. THE REASON WHY
WE ARE HERE IS BILLS BECAUSE OF
THE STRICT TIMELINE IN RELATION
TO THE SCOPING PLAN IT NEEDS TO
BE PREPARED STARTING NEXT YEAR.
THAT'S WHY THE PRIORITY. AND
THE SCOPING PLAN TO GET IS NON
BINDING IT IS NON REGULATORY-
IT SIMPLY MAPS OUT POSSIBLE
PATHWAYS. TO REACH OUR STATE'S
CLIMATE TARGETS. AND THAT THE
LEGISLATURE AND RELEVANT
AGENCIES CAN CONSIDER IN THE
YEARS AHEAD CAN CONSIDER IN THE
YEARS AHEAD. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR. RESPECT LAST NIGHT OF.
BARBECUE ALMOST THE BILL HAS IT
HAS- YEAH I THINK I THINK JERRY
SKINNER YES SIR. SOME OF THE
BILL IF YOU NOT. I DID YEAH I
BELIEVE CENTER COMMITTED BUT
YEAH YOU'RE YOU'RE A SO THE
BILLS MOVE BY CENTER SKINNER IF
IT FAST CONSULT COULD CALL THE
ROLL ITEM NUMBER FIVE AB NINE
FIFTY FOUR BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
RIVAS. THE MOTION IS PASSED THE
SENATE CREATIONS COMMITTEE
ALLEN. I ALLEN I'D BATES NO
BATES NO DALY NO DALLY NO HILL
ALL RIGHT HILL EYES SKINNER.
SKINNER R. X. HI. NINE STERN
AYE WHY CASKEY NOT TOTING A
CASCADE VOTE. AT FORWARD TO
OKAY FORTY TWO WE'RE GONNA
CLOSE THE ROLE ON THAT ITEM ALL
RIGHT MEMBERS- WE HAVE POSSIBLY
MISSED A FEW CALLERS IN
OPPOSITION AB TWENTY SEVEN
THIRTY ONE. SO YEAH I KNOW SO
THERE WAS SOMETHING THAT
HAPPENED AS IF THE IF THE
MODERATE CAN MAKE THE STATEMENT
THAT IF YOU'RE AN OPTICIAN AB
TWENTY SEVEN THIRTY ONE- WE
WILL PUT YOU INTO Q. AND- YOU
KNOW. GIVE MALIGNED NUMBER
THEY'LL BE ABLE TO SPEAK. THANK
YOU LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU'RE IN THE PORT OF AB TWENTY
SEVEN THIRTY ONE YOU MAY PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THE TIME. TO OPEN
MY NUMBER EIGHTY NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. I REMEMBER LEARNING-
THIS IS BRAND ALSO IS HERE
CALIFORNIA- I THINK YOU
YOURSELF AND ALL YOUR WORK ON
THIS BILL- I'M ACTUALLY IN
OPPOSITION OF THE BILL AND-
SORRY FOR SIMILARLY WE HAVE
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED POSITION
FOR. OUR LOCAL CHAPTER IS VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF THE TRYING TO
PROJECT THAT AB TWENTY ONE WAS-
IS COMMITTED TO THE CONCERNED
BUT WE STILL MORE MOVEMENT
UNNECESSARY TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE PROJECT YOU SHOULD LEARN BY.
MALES THE PROJECT AROUND THAT.
OF A DARK PROJECT YOU NEED TO
MAKE SURE THAT YOU ARE ADMITTED.%
AS ARE LOCAL BAND WHAT IN
CHANGING. NOT NECESSARILY THE
REST OF THE COUNTRY. SO WE LOOK
FOR TO WORKING WITH THE DOCTOR
RESOLVE ISSUES WE HAVE ON OTHER.
WITHIN THE BILL OR AND WE
APPRECIATE YOUR CHECKING ON THE
NEEDS SOME MISSION. YOU ALL ARE
AWARE. THANKS FOR YOUR TIME. MY
APOLOGIES I. IT DIDN'T MENTION
A- POLICE GENTLEMEN TO SHOW UP
IN. FOR AB TWO SEVEN THIRTY ONE
YOU MAY PRESS ONE TO. AT THIS
TIME. CHAU OPPOSITION EACH FIVE
THIRTY YOU MADE ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. AND ONCE AGAIN IF
YOU LIKE TO SHOW OPPOSITION YOU
MAY PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AND I HAVE NO ONE SHOWING
OPPOSITION FOR EITHER TWENTY
SEVEN THIRTY ONE THANK YOU
THANK YOU MATTER OKAY. LET'S
NOW TAKE THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
OPEN THE ROLE ON THE ITEMS THAT
TIME WHERE MEMBERS HAVE NOT
HAD. WE'RE NOT EVERYBODY'S WELL
ADD ON SO LET'S START WITH ITEM
ONE THIS IS AB SEVENTY THREE-
SAID A SEVEN MEMBER TEAMS BILL.
ON MINIMAL RISK MINIMUM
RECYCLED CONTENT. IT'S ON
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE WITH THE CHAIR VOTING
I'D- THE VOTE IS SIX ZERO STERN.
SKINNER STERN HI AT SEVEN ZERO
OKAY THANK YOU SO MUCH WE'LL
CLOSE THE ROLE ON THAT AND THEN
I THINK THE ONLY OTHER THING WE
HAVE TO DO THE CONSENT CALENDAR
IT THAT'S- THAT'S RIGHT INTO AB
TWENTY FIFTY TWENTY FIVE SIXTY.
CONSENT CALLIDUS CORK SPELL.
CONTROL THE KALRA. THE VOTE IS
FOUR ZERO WITH THE CHAIR VOTING
I. BATES HI BATES AYE SKINNER.
ALL RIGHT SKINNER AYE STERN.
SURE NINE STERN HI SEVEN ZERO
OKAY THANK YOU SO CLOSER ON
THAT CONSOLE CAN I JUST CLARIFY
THAT THERE NO MORE OUTSTANDING
VOTES. WRECKED OKAY FANTASTIC
WELL MEMBERS THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR YOUR PARTICIPATION THANK
YOU TO ALL OF THE ADVOCATES
THANK YOU THE STAFF. AS ALWAYS
FOR WORKING WHEN TO THESE VERY-
TRYING CIRCUMSTANCES WITH
COVED- BUT THAT BRINGS R. TWO
HEARINGS. OF ASSEMBLY BILLS TO
A CLOSE AND- I APPRECIATE THIS
AND WE WILL ADJOURN THIS
HEARING.